there was no news today thanks for
tuning in and we'll see you all next
week I'm just kidding no we actually do
have a show but we were making a joke
earlier that back in the day they used
to actually say that because they'd be
like there's not really any news so
let's just take the day off and send out
the message to everybody let them know
nothing's happening but there's always
going to be something happening and uh
we're just chilling on a Friday night
the truth is yeah there's a lot of news
and stink bugs I guess yeah so many but
uh there's you know the new story that's
coming out is the global food shortage
is coming because of the fertilizer
shortage now due to the conflict with
Russia and Ukraine Russia is not sending
out fertilizer which means fertilizer
costs are skyrocketing and that means
the crap yield is going to be like 40
down it's happening in Spring which
means come fall man your food's gonna
get really expensive not to mention all
the gas and all that stuff so you know
scary fear ah the world's ending and all
that or whatever but uh you know it's
Friday so we're gonna hang out we'll
talk about that we got a couple other
stories we've got uh Putin had a big
rally in Russia everyone's talking about
there's a glitch or something on TV uh
Dr fauci Who vanished for some time he's
got some uh uh Doom saying for us you
know apparently there's a new variant
and he's come out and he's like there's
a new variant put me back on TV and they
did so we'll just talk about that but I
think for the most we're going to talk
hanging out and just talking about
literally whatever because um I got to
be honest it's one of those days where
there is very little going on and it's
kind of relaxing you know because we'll
just we'll just make jokes and you know
be silly and have a good Friday night
and joining us to be funny is Andrew
Heaton hello I'm very funny it's a
pleasure to be here too thanks for
having me on a day with no news to
discuss yeah oh it's great yeah so the
pressure's on you you better talk I I
was I took a lot of Adderall and read
three issues of The Economist before I
came on for nothing oh is there anything
interesting in it uh
Singapore is that a Crossroads too
that's what I what I'm thinking out yeah
ah yes and the politics of Liechtenstein
uh yes let's let's talk about that uh so
who are you what do you do I'm a
political satirist and a podcast host so
uh I'm I'm funny I'm a contributor at
reason TV and I host a show funny I'm
well I'm not going to do it tonight
because I'm off duty it's a Friday okay
but if it were like a Monday around 11
A.M to 11 43 a.m I'm very funny during
that slot and I host a show called the
political orphanage which is a podcast
designed for people that don't feel like
they're being catered to by Red Team
Versus Blue Team media oh okay cool all
right then well thanks for coming thanks
good to see you okay I'll see myself out
thanks everybody and uh we got another
guy who makes fun of politics yeah my
name is Seamus Coughlin I also do
political satire for a YouTube channel I
created a while ago called Freedom Tunes
we just do satire about current events
sometimes we'll dive into deeper topics
and we also do educational cartoons
every now and again so that's pretty
exciting and a lot of fun so go check
that out we released a cartoon yesterday
on the industrial military complex and
now they're constantly using World War
II Nostalgia to get people invested in
new meddling in other countries and new
policies of meddling in other countries
and I think you guys will enjoy it it
was disturbingly awesome thank you Ian I
went out and bought war bonds
he really took it literally went over I
got a different them Nazis yeah exactly
that's correct welcome back uh hey
everyone Ian Crossland here welcome back
to me and back again after two days I
wasn't feeling very well so I I took a
couple days off and I decided to change
my diet really hard I hard left turn I
started eating only kimchi and aloe vera
in her filet with these internal Reds
knowing that it healed Me So within like
40 hours I I just I dodged like a
serious cold I could feel it coming on
and I was just like nope not gonna eat
the dry food because it was making me
dehydrated dude funniest the funniest
thing was that we had uh Congressman
Randy Weber who's on the energy
committee and he's you know if when the
Republicans win he'll be the chair and I
was just like the one time Ian really
needs to talk about graphene apparently
Tim misrepresented he was making I was
like she was like graphene's horrible I
wouldn't even look at it dude grapping
is Awesome by the way we should we
should go deeper into graphene tonight
yeah okay touchscreen wallpaper it's
hilarious I'm an idiot Ian was out sick
and here I was filling in for him not
taking the empty spot but sitting in his
desk with the microphone he breathes
into right in my face knowing he was
sick I didn't even consider it yeah man
that old guest Mike was the one you
gotta wipe that one down yeah I licked
your mic when I came in am I going to
get Ian he's gonna strengthen your
immunity we're trying to
before I forget I want to kick it over
to Lydia here who's uh also I am also
here that's true thank you Ian I'm here
in the corner I'm very excited for
Andrew Heaton I was listening to his
podcast biblical orphanage earlier today
and watching one of his videos hilarious
by the way I'm gonna have to make his
podcast part of my regular rotation can
I plug the latest episode you can yeah
so I have been watching all the Ukraine
footage I've been watching all the all
the the the breathless fighting between
Republicans and Democrats and I think
the actual fissures are deeper and
different than that so I did an episode
on that I did an episode on
international relations Theory which
sounds boring but is actually just the
DNA of War why is War caused and what
are the competing solutions to Warren so
that was the latest episode
we'll we'll definitely talk about that
but before we get started my friends
head over to
strongerbonesandlife.com and you can get
your ageless multi-collaget it's just
some powder you mix it in your drinks I
like mixing it into smoothies and coffee
and collagen is a protein you need for
your joints your hair your skin your
nails if you want to to be healthy if
you're like me you know I'm now 36 my
birthday was just the other week and I'm
an eight I'm an old man so I definitely
got to be taking this stuff to make sure
my bones and my joints work if you go to
stronger bones in life.com you will get
51 off your agents multicolagen you'll
get a 60-day money-back guarantee you
get the healthy aging support of
collagen its ideal forms five key types
of collagen from four different sources
for every order today BioTrust will
donate a nutritious meal to a hungry
child in your honor through their
partnership with no kidhungry.org to
date BioTrust has provided over 5
million meals to Hungry kids please help
bio trust hit their goal of 6 million
meals this year it is non-GMO and free
of artificial colors flavors
preservatives and sweeteners and free of
gluten antibiotics and rbgh and rbsd
nearly no odor or taste unlike bone
broth and other collagen supplements
there's no clumping you'll get free
shipping with every order free VIP live
health and fitness coaching from
BioTrust team of expert nutrition and
health coaches for life with every order
that's always crazy I can't believe when
I read that that's that's insane that's
a great deal for free new e-report the
14 foods for amazing skin with every
order again head over to strongerbones
in life.com thank you BioTrust for
sponsoring the show you guys know them
you love them and go to timcast.com be a
member and you'll be supporting our
journalists and the hard work they do
this is how we run the website it's how
we do the show you guys as members keep
all of this floating protecting us from
the evils of cancel culture it's true
the more members we have the stronger we
become like we're able to expand we're
able to be resilient in the face of
activists trying to shut us down so
that's one one way you can really
support us you'll also get members only
segments uh you'll be you'll be able to
watch those Monday through Thursday and
don't forget to smash the like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and uh let's just
let's just throw it into this first
story which is just more of a general
story and then we'll just have a fun
Friday Hangout
there's there's been a lot of news about
inflation
and gas and it seems like the new news
cycle that's starting to Bubble Up we're
getting from Politico from CNN from The
Washington Post and all these big
Outlets is that there's going to be a
global food shortage or that we're
already experiencing one not to mention
inflation is through the roof so we've
got a couple stories about there's this
billionaire who owns a chain of grocery
stores and he said buy your food now
because it's going to get really
expensive soon they're saying that
basically because Russia produces so
much fertilizer and now no one can trade
with them because of the war
we're going to see fertilizer costs
Skyrocket availability diminish crop
yields will drop by 40 percent come fall
is when everyone's going to get hit by
it that's the latest scary news in the
media and all has to do with the war and
that's going on so how you guys doing so
if if I can get a couple million bats
and bat guano I can Corner the market on
fertilizers okay Ian yes how do you feel
about going in on me in with me on a bad
investment in on me well the way you
asked me the questions
we'll talk later we'll discuss graphene
and bats okay yeah yeah that's uh maybe
we do need a little bit of nationalizing
uh fertilizer what I don't know
nationalizing food production never ends
well bro
it was a great way to murder Millions
way cheaper than nuclear weapons too
socialize socialized agriculture is the
best way to kill people it's actually a
really good point you know we we work so
hard on nuclear weapons to kill tons of
people when all we needed was communism
yeah exactly yeah the United States
should have didn't even need to drop
bombs on Japan we could have just
dropped communist pamphlets and then
communism like the agriculture is such a
good microcosm for that of like what the
Soviets would do is they'd go uh okay we
need more we need more crops so uh we're
gonna order all of the farmers you've
got to till twice as much land now and
the farmers went yeah okay and they just
lifted up the the uh the the what do you
call them the the Rudders the Rudders
are the tractors you could tell I'm a
farmer they lifted up the Rudders and
then they just drove really fast like
they just raked the top of it because
they don't have a any personal gain in
it and then like of course that meant
that all of the the bushels of wheat
declined and everybody started starving
to death in Ukraine the other the other
thing they would do is they would go to
the guy who knows how to farm kill him
yeah and then take someone who did not a
farm and put him in charge Cambodia is a
great example I mean Cambodia they
literally first like Cambodia they shot
anybody that had any kind of education
they just shot it to the point where if
you had glasses in you'd be up against
the wall this is pole pot yeah was he
like a subject of Mao or was he a friend
of Mao or inspired by Mao or something
he wasn't Not only was he inspired by
Mao he this is literally the name of
cambodia's communist program was the
Super Great Leap Forward not the Great
Leap Forward but the super great I think
it was my idea and they killed about a
quarter of the population doing that and
they literally they'd go okay the annual
crop yield of the average hectare of
Farmland in Cambodia let's say it's like
eight bushels or something they went
from now on everybody has to do 40
bushels and people would go uh hi I'm a
Steve door I don't know how to farm and
also there's a bunch of rocks here and
this like like that was it and like it
caused massive massive death yeah that
was the funny thing where um was it Mao
he was like Kill The Sparrows was that
yeah and then everybody locusts yeah
yeah yeah this is why don't let Tommy's
near food yeah
shout out shout out to Maduro oh boy oh
yeah what a great job there when he was
giving his National address and then
just pulls an empanada out from a drawer
and bites it really slowly and then puts
it back on TV for everyone to watch this
is how great capitalism is because
capitalism is like what are we worried
about getting fat that's what we're
worried about with capitalism is excess
Twinkies that's how great lately we just
produce all this stuff yeah I saw AOC as
a new ASMR video out I don't know if you
guys saw it she's like Whispering she's
like nope wait are you serious stop it
yeah she's legit Whispering into this no
you're not she's like me no I'm not are
you serious yes AOC did ASMR I don't
know if he was like just Whispering yeah
okay it's just whispering and she was
like people don't
they're actually socialists because no
one's a capitalist because no one has a
billion dollars what and I'm like
you know I don't I I I I was like in a
tweet something that was like mean and
then I was just like she's got a
dictionary right because that's not what
capitalism means technically she has a
degree in economics that's the thing
that really irritates us she no I
believe she's still no she clearly
didn't sit through any of the classes
that drives me nuts because I'm gonna
spend the rest of my life having to go
no the definition of socialism is the
government owns the means of production
that's the definition of socialism it
doesn't mean sharing that would make the
Koch brothers socialists but what you
fail to realize is that the definition
of capitalism is you have a billion
dollars oh that's right oh that explains
it Sheamus you're so smart yeah well I'm
glad I could inform you so in communism
they own the production socialism they
also own the production what's the
difference there there's actually debate
about that the distinction between
communism and socialism some people say
that communism is the end State and
socialism comes in between others say
that communism wasn't is when the
government completely controls culture
and economy whereas under socialism
they're just controlling economy well it
isn't really completely let me let me
tell you what the lefties say they say
social is an economic system and
communism is a political system in
socialism you can have a variety of
social issues you get a variety of
um you know like church Short gay
marriage but the economic system is the
means of production are owned by the
people and they believe in full out
socialism there's like there's no you
know there would be no um I don't say no
currency but there's no like private
trade of goods whereas communism is
everyone's equal on every on every issue
and then so communism includes issues
like gay marriage whereas socialism is
just economic so would it be like
socialism is to Communism as capitalism
is to democracy yeah but that that is a
no no this is distinction capitalism
economic State and democracy is the
governmental political State not
necessarily I mean capitalism can exist
under multiple systems sure yeah yeah
exactly there are many who argue
democracy and capitalism are opposed to
one another yeah yeah saying uh yeah
exactly like socialism and communism are
uh socialism is a large component of
communist ideas like it can't exist one
can't exist communism cannot exist
without socialism but we're also
approaching this as westerners from a
liberal democracy because as Sheamus
rightly points out the commies didn't
think this way like if you go back and
you look at Soviet manifestos like but
like back in the 80s like you see like
uh uh the the Soviet Premier would say
we believe we can achieve communism in
the next 10 years right so like to an
American that sounds very odd for the
Soviet Union to say it's not it's not
communist but the way kami's thought was
socialism is our Economic Policy
communism is when the withering of the
state occurs and the proletariat becomes
the kind of the indole right that like
we the last 30 years we've made a
distinction of socialist countries are
socialist countries that are cute that
we like and communist countries or
socialist countries that we find scary
yeah and and capitalism for those for
those that don't know is literally just
when private individuals have the
ability to trade amongst each other yeah
yeah the private sector meaning charity
individuals and corporations it means
that capitalism would be you as an
individual does decide that your labor
has value and you decide what you're
willing to exchange it for in socialism
you don't get to decide what your labor
is worth you just get what's available I
mean Central planners determine where
your labor should be allocated and to
your point this is why you constantly
hear commies saying that real communism
has never been tried because they're
talking about a theoretical end state
which has never existed communism they
sure killed a lot of people trying to
get there yeah exactly real communism
they did some heavy lifting to try and
get there yeah also this is hilarious
because they say Communism works and
they say real communism's never been
tried and how on Earth could you know if
it works if it's never been tried it
sounds like they tried it for 100 years
and failed it just yeah they failed to
achieve their end goal well you could I
mean on like like it sounds so weird for
me to say I think they could be right if
you tried it with 150 people and anybody
in that group could leave whenever they
wanted
communism because it's not it's not the
course absolutely like a family's
communist we've talked about this in the
past in unlike it's like the valence
levels of behavior in your family it's
very communists
get your city it's socialists you have
firemen and they're working from
socialism and that's not the greater
whole we're more democratic we're not
socialism fire departments are not
socialism police department social
programs are not socialism socialism is
when the factory is owned by the state
yeah having like the fire department
it's owned by the city so you having
some components of emergency services
that are provided to you through Social
Services is not socialism it's not
socialism you can call it social welfare
programs hybrid this is what happens
with uh Denmark and and you know Bernie
Sanders is like they're socialists and
then the Prime Minister comes out and he
says no we're not the Prime Minister
flew to America to remind he's like no
we are actually a market economy we're a
market economy that has a robust welfare
state exactly which is a Nuance that is
very much lost on Bernie Sanders who has
converted the word socialism to mean
sharing so yeah is the fire department
part like welfare is it considered
welfare I would I would say you could
say that in a sense yeah well first of
all fire department actually varies
quite a lot in the United States about
half of the fire department the United
States are private voluntary
organizations about half of them are
some combination of publicly funded and
things like that so the idea that all
fire departments are a public government
organization the same way like police
departments are would be a misnomer
um I think I don't know I I could kind
of like I could kind of go either way on
that because like theoretically an army
could be a mercenary Army right but we
don't we don't tend to have those we
tend to have uh you know an actual
military that is paid for by by
taxpayers and things you can have uh
like bodyguards and things like that so
fire departments aren't producing things
they're emergency services so I think
it's fair to say there's a distinction
between you open up a cracker Factory in
the government's like no no we control
how this operates because it's going to
be equal you would make the distinction
between economic productivity or just
economic production versus services
well not necessarily Services because
Services could be anything I mean
delivery services the post office I just
think it's fair to say that uh the fire
department is not socialism the fire
department isn't the means of production
it's Emergency Services yeah so
emergency services are different from
Services the post office is not an
emergency service the post office we
could argue should be privatized you
know FedEx and UPS are better I argue
that quite a lot actually I guess yeah
occasionally people call me from NPR and
be like you want to come talk about this
there are there are some questions about
uh why the White's important the fire
department be sort of nationalized sort
of
um private a lot of areas that have
volunteer fire departments they do
because they don't have the resources to
sustain large salaried fire departments
but one of the one of the issues with uh
fire departments as to why it might make
sense to have it be sort of like a you
know look we're going to cover all fire
is because fire spreads right and if the
police department showed up and said
this guy doesn't pay us right we don't
service him it's like what are you going
to do put the fire up for the buildings
next to it not we're all too close to
each other just put the fire out and
well to figure it out yeah that's I'm
those are negative externalities are a
legitimate role for government in my
opinion you know like if you've got like
smog smog doesn't obey property lines
right so like that's a situation where
it makes sense to have some kind of
adjudicating service but if I want to
make and sell shoes having the shoe
department where you've got to go apply
at the government office and then pass
some you know affirmative you know
action tests or you know diversity test
and then they allow you to be a
Shoemaker that's a problem and if and if
there were a federal shoe department and
you and I came in and went you know we
think the private sector could probably
handle this people would think we're
monsters if I if I said we should
privatize the federal shoe department
because the the Milwaukee Public factory
makes way too many left shoes news and
the uh the Oregon factory makes
insufficient right shoes so we're making
people wear two left shoes I think the
private sector can handle this people
would go you want people to walk around
barefoot in America and you're a monster
you know the problem with the Department
of Education people want that and it's
and I think privatized or at least sent
around localized is that when you it's
no longer federalized then how do you or
how do you organize it how do you make
sure everyone's getting like a similar
shoe size how do you make sure that your
size 11 is the same as his size 11 if
you're at different companies with no
government over so arguably it's not
doing it now right I mean the federal
government basically just tries to bribe
State education departments with grants
like with uh No Child Left Behind and
that kind of thing but the actual
government or the actual curriculum is
still done at the state level and the
funding is not the local level yeah
exactly I mean the Department of
Education has only been around since the
late 1970s so it's not as if this is
integral to our public education system
and even if it was it would still
probably get really bad because our
public education system is horrible yes
I think Massey said it would free up 400
million dollars a year again flip it if
the if the private sector if we just had
like charter schools and that was all
the schools in America right now and we
were looking at test scores people would
go man the private sectors really failed
we needed we need to change this but
when the government does it we never go
man the government's still screwing this
up we should privatize this yeah well so
that's the way I describe it is with
these social programs uh well I'll I'll
start by saying all laws should have
Sunset Clauses you know all bills being
passed through Congress and the same is
true for all social programs I like the
idea that we're like okay we got a
serious issue right we've got Mass
homelessness we're going to need a major
public works program that's fine to me
as long as it's got like a finite limit
on when it expires because what happens
is they come out and they say we need a
Department of Education we need public
schools because we need our kids to be
educated and then a few years ago was by
and the kids are suffering and doing
worse and so the way I describe this is
the United States with a festering wound
they slap a bandage on it they say we'll
just cover that up with a nice little
bandage and then a few years goes by and
they look at it now smoldering and
infested and worse and they say let's
just put another bandage on top of that
and just what they do is they keep
dumping money into failing programs so
you think they're fixing it but they're
not really fixing it yeah right so
they're saying hey we're going to fix it
with this money and you go oh thank you
and then you walk away and then they
don't actually fix it they make it worse
you can't falsify that either like if
we're going to approach policy making
scientifically you can't disprove a
negative right uh like like if any any
government program you ever put out
there fails the proponents often can go
it was insufficiently funded that
applies literally every single time yeah
we failed so give us more money it would
have worked if they've given us money
because but there's never going to be
enough money for everybody to have what
they want yeah it's hilarious you see
you see political leaders do this a lot
too like I didn't achieve everything I
was supposed to in my first term which
is why you need to give me a second you
know what sometimes it can be legitimate
I just want to mention this one Milton
Friedman quote there is nothing so
permanent as a temporary government you
know what
about the government just get rid of it
all yeah did it fall all thing about
government yeah I just I want a boutique
government I want a little like compact
icon nobody no government for anybody
nobody gets any government there's none
uh am I the status here I did not see no
no all right I think there should be a
government I just think it should
basically protect us from bears and
maybe Communists we need an agile
government that changes when the
technology changes like we should be
working more online the government's so
slow to adapt they're so happy getting
their paychecks and just going to work
and here's where I disagree I actually
think the government's too quick to
adapt I wish they they moved a lot more
slowly than they did powdered wigs when
was like the first paper on graphene
that I ever saw no just like what that
you can think of like the first big 2004
is when it was 2004 discovered so so
we're looking at what are we at 97 18
years and the US government has not been
is not made of graphene I've never heard
someone in the government mentioned the
word unless they're sitting across from
me and I say it to them and they repeat
me it's crazy yesterday whenever we have
a politician and or you know Ian's like
graphene like now's my chance you guys
should be looking at this as if like
who's the best government in the world
to produce the most miraculous substrate
in the planet Earth it's pretty carbon
you know I'm somewhat kidding about the
government being made of graphene but I
think it's a good it's a good example of
Nancy Pelosi is a how old you know 80.
98. look the left and the right agree on
this that we know there's an age of
retirement and an age at which people
start to deteriorate yet our government
is run exclusively by you know
septuagenarians and octogenarians maybe
maybe with all due respect these these
people should be given an opportunity to
retire off into the sunset and just to
relax the coconut in a cigar or
something Have you ever heard of uh El
Presidente Salazar of Portugal this is a
can I tell you it's a very quick story
but this is one of my favorite stories
so uh Portugal had one of those dick
presidents for life like I think it was
in the 60s or the 70s but he's like El
Presidente but he's he's a dictator
right he has a stroke and he is on his
deathbed in the rubber stamped
parliament of Portugal goes all right
enough of this nonsense it's time to go
back to being a democracy let's join the
rest of Europe we're going to be a
liberal democracy uh okay everybody all
in favor we're we're a democracy now but
then he recovers and they go oh oh oh
but he's like he's okay but he's kind of
winded so what they do is they send him
to like the presidential Winter Palace
and for the next three years of his life
they don't tell him he's been ousted and
they send in lying orderlies to come in
every day and go ah yes Mr President we
did as you said and we firebombed Lisbon
or whatever and they just give him like
a like he's living in Truman's show for
three the last three years of his life I
think it's a great thing to do with
dictators
give up give him a fake send off yeah
that's what they do in Napoleon I mean
they knew they can't martyr the guy
though he knew he was he didn't he
didn't realize he didn't think he was
running Paris that would have been funny
oh yeah he knew he was he knew he was
yeah that's why a lot of people
recommended that or a lot of the left
was saying about Trump you know put him
in a fake White House and then just film
it into a reality show where he thinks
he's President part of me thinks that's
what's happening with Biden you know
like he's sitting there thinking he's
playing video games but Kamala handed
him a controller that's not plugged in
and she's exactly the one doing it you
have it backwards yeah the American
people are being shown a TV screen it's
so true and they're and we're being told
he's the president yeah yeah well
exactly I mean I'm pretty sure things
are being run by the people around him
the man can't finish a sentence well I
don't I don't you know I I've said this
several times I think the people around
him are trying to do what Biden wants
but a man that incoherent makes it
impossible so they're all you know the
joke is like they're all sitting around
the table and you know and you've got uh
Millie and like Kamala and then Biden's
like oh this uh Ukraine thing yeah come
on man did you get a uh what come on and
then they're all sitting around looking
at each other like uh what do we do what
did he say he wants us to do and then
Trump was like you got you got Vladimir
Putin you get him on the phone and turn
it on a shot of the pressure and they're
like okay and then they all get up and
leave the room and they're all looking
each other like what are you supposed to
do I have no idea what did he say and
then they just start pressing random
buttons they're like we're working Biden
so they're technically the ones doing
things but it's like without without a
nucleus without a cohesive core guiding
you like you know for all Donald Trump's
faults he was telling people to do
things you know and they would do them
and things worked out now Joe Biden is
muttering to himself at the time and
they're just pressing random buttons
hoping something happens look you look
at the Afghanistan withdrawal who in
their right mind would be like we're
going to withdraw from the Bagram Air
Force Base in the middle of the night
without telling the Afghan Security
Forces then we're going to try and
evacuate people to the civilian airport
once everyone's found out hold on if if
our main goals just to do it on the
anniversary of 9 11. if that's the top
goal it makes sense if you're just doing
it for symbolic purposes if that's your
top your top people I I think I looked
at the 2020 election and I thought
America had a choice between uh getting
on a train that keeps getting lost or
getting on a train that hits cows for
fun I I thought it was a really really
bad uh choice that we all had to make on
that one this is the problem with um
first past the post voting systems yes
yeah you end up with two two people and
everyone just hates the other one so
much they vote for the other one and you
end up with you know look in 2016 I was
like I'm not voting for Trump and
Hillary Clinton yeah right I'm
definitely not voting for Hillary
Clinton when 2020 came around with
critical race Theory and everything that
was going on and then Trump released his
uh uh you know second term campaign
positions I was like I'll vote for that
you know it's it's not so bad what would
like because I I'm unfamiliar with your
your whole Arc I know that you used to
be a Bernie guy right oh yeah so he's
already lost his mind so okay so so it
like I wondered if maybe it's just
you're a populist and probably is that
it oh Bernie Sanders in 2015. open
borders is the Koch brothers proposal so
you know look I've got this on behalf of
the neoliberal shills we rather like
open borders we've been in favor of that
for a while so with Bernie you've got a
guy who's supported by a lot of working
class guys he says on stage to debate
the gun control debate is an urban
versus rural issue and people in Vermont
like guns so it's not Democrat
Republican or whatever there are
Democrats or like guns and I'm like you
know I appreciate hearing this because I
think and and back then I was not a
staunch you know 2A absolutist for the
most part I was like I think there's
some reasonable discussion there but it
felt it felt reasonable because I know
that people who live in rural areas have
a different expectation on guns so I
lived in um on in in rural you know
outside of Miami in the Redlands back in
I think this was 2015. and so I
understood what was going on in the
neighborhood as to why people liked guns
there were illegal immigrants who were
committing crimes and killing people and
it happened in in this area and so all
of a sudden I'm like I I think I
understand why people are having these
conversations but Bernie Sanders you
know just quickly went full-on
neoliberal Dem Democrat establishment
Hillary Clinton open borders and I was
like I don't even know what the guy
stands for at this point nothing having
a bunch of houses and saying if you want
to have several houses you can write a
best-selling book
Donald Trump was a blowhard he was
bombastic but uh with 2020 you have his
push against critical race theory he
banned not explicitly critical race
Theory but the tenets of CRT which
violate the 1964 Civil Rights Act he
banned that from government contracts
and in government training which is
really really good I knew Biden would
overturn that and once again bring
racist whites like overtly white
supremacist ideology segregation back
into government under the guise of not
being white supremacist and they would
accuse the people who are fighting for
civil libertarianism of being the racist
so I'm like that's one for Trump trump
set a timeline for what's wrong out of
Afghanistan I said I'd like to see that
followed through look at what Biden did
hey I was right to vote for Trump Joe
Biden screwed that up miserably Donald
Trump is also forced didn't Biden delay
the timeline he delayed the time and
then he screwed up the withdrawal
outright okay so Donald Trump's
surrender how do you think it rendered
the difference than what Trump would
have done in terms of Afghanistan so so
uh there's a question why even Bill
Maher mentioned why didn't Vladimir
Putin invade Ukraine under Trump
Donald Trump was a Madman is a Madman uh
to the point where the left said he's a
madman and the right was like he's a
madman and I'm like I think we all agree
he's a Madman but um you know in varying
ways right the right was like he's he's
eccentric and he's gonna do it he's
going to do shocking things uh Trump
said recently that he was talking to
Putin and said if you go into Ukraine
I'll I'll hit Moscow I'll nuke Moscow
and he's like hey he believed me a
little bit maybe five ten percent but
it's enough right I don't like that idea
that our president's going to be like
I'll kill 10 million civilians
but then you look at you know what Trump
was actually doing during this whole
conflict we saw the crushing of Isis
which Russia was probably like okay well
you know this guy's not crushing my
allies like the the Obama Administration
was doing with Syria and basically
arming the rebels in the Middle East
when he was talking about withdrawing
from NATO which would be very pleasing
to Russia right so if I was Russia and
the president was talking about
withdrawing from NATO I would not want
to antagonize you know but he wouldn't
want to give them a rational acceptance
if you if you understand Trump you
understand he plays What's called the
big ask what Trump was saying and many
argue he saved NATO Trump went to Nato
and said you're not paying your fair
share for military and you're expecting
the American people to do it I hear that
and I'm like I that is right that is
true I'm absolutely sick of the USB they
all have the the social welfare programs
they have is because they don't have the
military we have and then military and
if Russia encroaches on them we have to
foot the bill for them while the people
here crap you know talk crap about us
because look at those countries and
everything they get it's like yeah
because our troops are over there and
they shouldn't be well what ends up
happening is they start paying a little
bit more what did Trump say when he went
to he went to this NATO meeting and he
said Germany you're dependent on Russia
Why is the the U.S footing the bill for
NATO to protect you from Russia and then
you're dependent on their oil to keep
doing deals with them he was right about
all that so the reason why I think
Vladimir Putin didn't invade Ukraine
partly is because Trump is a bit
what's the right word for unpredictable
and a little crazy right erratic erratic
good work erratic okay and so Putin
genuinely I would imagine to a certain
degree was probably like I'm not sure
what he would do if I made these moves
now Biden he's predictable but with
Donald Trump you get the crushing of
Isis Syria is Russia's Ally we don't
like Isis the United States liked Isis
the government did because it was
destabilizing the Assad regime and the
United States and Western Powers wanted
to build a pipeline through Syria so it
was also convenient for the West to be
like uh oh we accidentally gave weapons
to a bunch of jihadis trump goes in and
blows them all up you can say for better
for worse the drone strikes and all that
stuff but Isis was decimated under Trump
so of course Vladimir Putin isn't
invading the one way these left these
leftists like to put it is they're like
because Trump was playing to Putin's
agenda and I'm like crushing Isis
staying out of Ukraine's Affairs and
actually like allowing things to
semi-stabilize like the Abraham Accords
oh it's no wonder Putin was so upset but
if you're if you're like that's Putin's
agenda what's your agenda war war in
Eastern Europe War in the Middle East I
don't want any of that I don't think we
should be the World Police so when I saw
what Trump was doing I said I like these
things it's enough for me to vote for
though with he Trump tried getting our
troops out of Syria you know what
happened a high-breaking official lied
to the American people about how many
troops were in Syria to keep them there
it's insane that is our
commander-in-chief saying the American
people want our troops out and I'm gonna
make it happen and they said yeah don't
worry Trump there's only 200 left Trump
tried getting them all out and they said
we can't do it because of the oil so
Trump publicly comes out and says we're
going to keep 200 people in there you
know uh for the oil and he blurts it out
and I'm like good tell people what we're
doing there and why we're doing it you
know what happens one of the first
things one of the first reports we get
when Biden gets back in office is that
U.S troops are moving through Syria
again do you think Vladimir Putin was
happy about that but Syria is an ally of
Russia and and Russia has a naval base
in Tartus so when the U.S is in a
country that Russia is allied with it's
not surprising that Putin's gonna be
like you know fires you missiles or
whatever so look Donald Trump far from
perfect for a lot of ways I believe that
he represents the worst of American
culture you know talking privately on a
bus or whatever about what you know
women let you do it you know all of
these things are crude and crass he does
not represent the office very well in
terms of decorum but when you look at
how corrupt the Democratic establishment
has been and are today and how they've
kicked off all of this conflict
I think Donald Trump would have been uh
the much better choice I believe that if
Donald Trump was still in office the
Afghanistan withdrawal would have gone I
wouldn't say swimmingly but much much
better I don't believe those there could
have gone much worse it was a surrender
you surrendered no no no U.S surrendered
Joe Biden surrendered Joe Biden's
Administration abandoned the Bagram Air
Force Base in the middle of the night
without notifying the Afghan Security
Forces when The Afghani Marines were
fighting for their lives Joe Biden did
nothing to assist them in fact they
didn't even know what Biden was doing
whenever I abandoned an Air Force Base I
always text always everything just so
you FYI FYI 11 pm I'm going away Andrew
it's it's it's it's considered proper to
do it in person you know you know what I
tend to ghost I know you're not breaking
up
like I don't really like Canada anymore
I'm just it'll figure it out it'll
figure it out take a look at uh Keystone
Pipeline getting shut down so anyway
back to uh may I add a little bit to
your Russian timeline here I right so uh
I first of all to key off of something
you're bringing up something that I'm
very much bothered by in American
discourse right now is the phrase uh
Putin apologist now I don't like Putin
and if you do like Putin you're in a
Putin apologist and you're wrong and you
deserve poone's a scumbag program yes
very much so but like like if if you're
just saying like I don't think it's a
good idea for NATO to indefinitely
expand and because uh Putin would agree
with you you're a Putin apologist like
if you were opposed to going into Iraq
are you a Saddam apologist like I think
in retrospect we're like that was a
really bad idea but I think a lot of the
same voices that are kind of this neocon
muscular liberalism are going well if
you're saying anything other than my
militant proposals you are a Putin
apologist and it's like no there's more
than two options yeah right and and one
of them is like it might be a an
imprudent idea so I look at Russia and
uh I I see this more from a realist
perspective um which is that there are
great Powers
um we are we're concerned about the
interplay of powers the power dynamics
Russia views Ukraine almost like we view
Canada if all of our historic enemies
had marched through Canada to try to
murder us over 300 years and they were
very upfront that like we will view any
uh annexation of Ukraine into NATO as an
existential threat very similar to how
we would feel if Canada joined Russia in
an alliance we would have the same
mindset here by the way all of these are
aimoral statements I'm not saying
Russia's good I'm just saying this is
how they're interpreting it outside of
this
um in 2000 2008 George W bush during the
Bucharest Summit goes yeah we're going
to bring in Ukraine to Nato like we're
just we're going to do it we don't know
when but we are bringing Ukraine into
NATO
Putin freaks out what does he do later
that year two months later he invades
Georgia the other country that was
mentioned in that bush says we're going
to bring in Georgia and Ukraine he he
brings in uh Georgia
um starts agitating things uh in uh um
in was it when Biden was vice president
we start beginning this process of
trying to Pivot Ukraine to the American
sphere in 2014 their pro-russian
president has ousted a new guy comes in
that's pro-america
a day later a day later uh Russia begins
taking Crimea where they have a naval
base where they already had a naval base
there was no strategic reason to do that
I mean that was because they were
freaking out about all this well no
there's a strategic reason to take
Crimea they have a naval base there it's
their only warm water Port right right
let me let me rephrase this they already
have the the military stuff there that
they need so if it's additional moves
that they're doing it's because they are
concerned about how the country's
pivoting and they're afraid it might go
in a different direction uh and then uh
you have in 2021 now that Biden's and I
so so Trump did agitate Russia at one
point because the authorized arms sales
to Ukraine and he fired 59 tomahawk
missiles into Syria yeah hitting an
airport so so it it's so he's he's not
like completely isolationist in that
regard once Biden gets into office we
have Anthony blinken as the Secretary of
State we also uh we we sign a U.S
Ukrainian cooperation agreement which is
further attempting to bring Ukraine into
our orbit and then we sealed the deal
um I think it was in November of last
year by doing joint they Naval exercises
with Ukraine and the Black Sea which
would again be like if Canada did Naval
exercises with Russia and Lake Superior
and at that point I think that's where
the the camel the Stars broke the camels
back well there's there's a lot more
um to this I think one of the reasons
Vladimir Putin didn't invade Ukraine one
of them is that uh Donald Trump stumbled
upon the corruption of Joe Biden in
Ukraine when he did that phone call and
that perfect phone call they say or he
says when he said look you know I saw
this video about Joe Biden bragging
about withholding Aid or whatever if you
could look at that what was that all
about and uh I don't think Donald Trump
really knew what that was all about just
something he saw on the internet but
they impeached him for it why well as it
turns out the laptop story was all true
Joe Biden was involved with illicit
dealings with his son through Ukraine
we've got the barisma which is paying
Joe Biden's son 83 000 a month or
arguably more depending on which source
you're using and uh then there's the
story about 10 for the big guy
I think when you look at Politico
reported this I don't know the 10 for
the big guys that a Biden reference
there was an email
um that came out where uh it was you
know like Devin Archer and
um Hunter Biden his associates I want to
be careful here because I don't have the
specifics pulled up but it was Hunter
Biden Associates talking about how
they're going to be splitting up one of
their business dealings and they said
and I'll take an extra 10 for the big
guy or something of that effect and um
everyone believes that's Joe Biden
because you know it's Joe Biden's the
guy who controlled all the influence we
know that Joe and Hunter Biden shared
bank accounts and so right right away
it's
you know and then there's a text message
from Hunter where he's talking wait hold
on actually I want to back up on that
really because like oh yeah um I I look
at the situation I'm gonna be honest
with you I have more of a mainstream
approach to this so this is new
information to me and I'm intrigued by
this I looked at that and I went it
appears that the president of the United
States is extorting an ally or at least
a Cooperative power yes how is he
extorting them uh by withholding defense
money in order to try and get them to
Target that's literally what Trump was
investigating Biden doing Joe Biden is
on video saying I want you to fire this
prosecutor otherwise you're not getting
a billion dollars and they said this is
a Joe Biden's quote he goes they said
you can't do that you're at the
president he goes call them call them
you got six hours
six hours you don't get the billion
dollars well son of a [ __ ] he got fired
now you want to know sorry I've got to
finish this you want to know why Joe
Biden got the prosecutor fired
the prosecutor Victor shulkin currently
had at minimum 12 investigations into
barisma's founder Michaela zlachevski
this is this is reporting from Matt
taibi and shoken signed a sworn
affidavit saying he was fired because
Joe Biden was interfering in Internal
Affairs in the country and the president
went to him and says he's forcing us to
fire you my colosse is deeply corrupt
they had Frozen his assets before he had
fled the country before but as soon as
this new prosecutor gets in under thanks
to Joe Biden dude comes on back dude
founds a company where Joe's son works
at the very least you can say Joe just
didn't know that his son worked for the
company Joe says I never talked to my
son about his business dealings then
thanks to the laptop we learn that's not
true Joe Biden shared a bank account
with his son while his son will see that
the bank account bids the part that's oh
yeah it's interesting because like you
you could make an argument here let's
theoretically let's say that uh Hunter
Biden is getting money
um because he can just soak the cash up
and they're basically trying to Biden by
giving money to his son well you could
be an impeachable person and have
somebody try to bribe you by giving
money to your son but if they're sharing
bank accounts that means that that
firewall's gone Joe Biden could become
embroiled in the FBI's probe and to
Hunter's finances experts say emails
revealed a shared bank accounts paid
each other's bills and the president may
have even funded his son's 2018 drug and
prostitution binge now if if Hunter
Biden is getting money working for an
energy company which has no business and
he's sharing a bank account with his dad
and a prosecutor is investing in
investigating that company and then his
dad comes in and says fire him or I'm
going to I'm going to withhold U.S
allotted funding that is so beyond
criminal and corrupt I am shocked that
when Donald Trump catches this on
accident and has no idea what it is and
says what's going on here they impeached
him for it these people are deeply
deeply evil look at this I mean come on
man when to quote Joe Biden how about
that come on come on man Joe Biden is in
photos with Hunter and a with Hunter and
and uh Hunter's Associates and he lied
and said I didn't talk to my son about
this stuff no I'll tell you what it is
Politico reported this a while back it's
called Biden Inc that the Biden family
fortunes track alongside his political
career when Joe Biden was put in charge
of Iraq under Obama all of a sudden his
brother is getting these lucrative
contracts for construction in the
country now you have Hunter Biden
working at a company in which everyone
knows he has no business working at no
expertise doesn't speak the language
sharing bank accounts Joe Biden comes in
gets the prosecutor who's investigating
the founder gets him fired threatening
to threatening to withhold funds from
the U.S government he has no right to do
Beyond abuse of power and then what do
they do the media comes out and lies
they get Trump impeached for it and now
here we are with many people in this
country still believing Trump was the
one who was wrong for trying to get rid
of that corruption now truth be told I
don't think Trump is a great detective
who was like I must do what's right and
save this country over this no I think
Trump saw a meme video a meme that went
viral of Joe Biden saying son of a [ __ ]
got fired and Trump's on the phone he's
like what was that video about if you if
you look at the transcript it's very
much Trump bumbling into something you
have to ask yourself why are so many
high-ranking Democrat family members
involved in ukrainians energy companies
I think it's because the U.S policy on
Ukraine was that we were it's not just
Ukraine it's Syria it's the Middle East
the cutter turkey pipeline was we are
going to destroy Russia's ability to
control natural gas into Europe because
gas is too expensive and we're going to
do it by any means necessary in 2009 it
was it was reported by the guardian I
believe in 2012 that in 2009 the US
government had stated we wanted to
invade Syria because Bashar al-assad was
blocking our allies from building a
pipeline through Syria and turkey
specifically because Syria said we are
allies with Russia and we won't allow it
then we ended up with our adversaries I
think it was Iran are saying they could
tap the same gas field and run it
through Iraq and into Europe and
strengthen Russia's gas Monopoly so the
U.S has to do a few things they need to
control gas prom which runs through
Ukraine and they need an alternative
source of fuel surprise surprise Syria
Falls in a civil war the U.S starts
funding the jihadis Russia's pissed then
we start getting these these pro-western
you know protests now there's there's a
there's a lot of people saying it was a
CIA backed coup I'm not going that far
I'm saying the west of course is playing
their influence game the West doesn't
want to pay these prices for gas Russia
doesn't want them to to screw around
with war and destroying their allies to
undercut their energy business but more
importantly if the U.S policy on Ukraine
was to gain control to reduce the cost
of energy for our European allies it
appears that Joe Biden and many other
high-profile individuals saw that and
said it's time to wet our beaks a little
on this one get our family members in
there so we can cut a profit while it's
all going down
what is fascinating about this and what
I'm very much enjoying about this in
addition to learning a lot is right now
most of the debate happening in foreign
policy circles in the United States is
between realists which is what I was
talking about earlier power billiard
balls Otto von Bismarck that kind of
thing realists right and liberals which
in an IR context don't think American
liberals think institution Builders NATO
European Union WTO right those are the
two big fights right now one of the
other schools of foreign policy that's
not a big part of the American
experience at the moment and and don't
freak out when I use this word but it's
Marxist so Marxist IR theory is that
it's not about power it's not about
institutions it's about money that that
you can look at international relations
and you can understand them by looking
at the ruling class of a country
enriching itself and this is fascinating
Tim because I'm not trying to throw any
socialist aspersions at you I'm just
saying like your heuristic window is
more economically motivated so you've
got a very different interpretation of
this than most of the other news I've
been consuming lately and I find it very
interesting well well I mean I I
absolutely look at the the ideological
backing of a lot of this too Vladimir
Putin very much wants to restore the
might of the of the former Soviet Empire
he wants the Russian Empire back he
wants that trade Union so very much he's
looking at countries like Kazakhstan for
instance and he's saying how can I build
up my own block to compete with NATO but
but uh ultimately it's I think a lot of
people have a simplistic view on things
you know I talk to my friends and I ask
them do you think Vladimir Putin is
intentionally trying to kill civilians
they'll say yes and I ask them why do
you think that is you know typically
people say it's because he's a bad guy
you know he wants to show the world how
powerful and scary is is evil and I'm
like isn't that a little naive you know
I certainly think Vladimir Putin is
killing civilians there's videos of it
and it's it's ridiculous to think that
he's that he's not
um but I don't think Vladimir Putin gets
up and says I'm going to kill civilians
today I think he's like this is a very
strategic Target for us in Kiev where
Ukrainian forces are using it is a
civilian Target hit it anyway I think
it's it's more nuanced it's things like
that I think any time you hear people
going he's mad that's lazy right like
it's possible but very unlikely
generally speaking when when somebody
who's previously made rational if
immoral unethical decisions which
they're not the same thing you can be
rational and unethical Allah Darth Vader
um when somebody has a track record of
doing that you're like I don't
understand what he's doing he's probably
crazy that means that your heuristics
are probably off and you need to
reassess what their motivations are yeah
it's a complicated uh uh world we live
in it's it's not just oil yeah you don't
think geopolitics is just black hats
versus white hats all the time although
that's all I think it's more nuanced
than that uh the US government can do no
wrong they've never lied to us
the fact that we only make allies based
on liberal democracy that's why we're
such good friends with Saudi Arabia you
know that Republican democratic
government with a Hayek and open market
and individual rights and we're very
anti-fascist which is of course why
we're absolutely opposed to the Nazis
and the azov Battalion yeah and
mercenaries we wouldn't hire like black
water you know a bunch of Dirty Work in
the Middle East or anything here's what
I tell people I I certainly think that
for the Elites in this country they view
cultural issues as somewhat secondary
like I don't think Nancy Pelosi knows or
cares all that much about what gen Z
thinks culturally I think a lot of it is
how can you control systems but you know
I I think
you know what I tell people is when it
came to Hillary Clinton and Donald Trump
I would tell my friends do you like it
that you know you can work in New York
at a media company where you write
articles about Brad Pitt's junk and get
paid sixty five thousand dollars a year
like are you happy with the amount of
money you make in the job you have and
they typically are like well you know I
probably should make more and so I'm
like okay would you prefer it if you had
to I don't know shovel coal for five
dollars an hour would that be a better
life for you and they're like what no of
course not I say okay let me explain to
you why you get to work in New York City
why you get paid 65 000 a year to write
articles once a week about Brad Pitt's
junk doesn't that seem a little wrong to
you like something's wrong with the
system where you basically do nothing of
value but you're making what is that
seven or eight times what people in
Mexico or Brazil make is that straight
yeah it's because of the Petro dollar
it's because of U.S the war machine it's
because the United States it's it's
special interest groups are willing to
destroy countries to get cheap Fuel and
cheap energy
and the Petro dollar helps helps us very
much so in that we don't need to rely on
exports for a strong currency we just
point guns at people and say you better
use ours this again this is interesting
because this is marxistar Theory like
marxistar Theory there's a subset of
called World systems theory and the idea
in World systems theory is that there's
an industrialized core of capitalist
countries there's a semi-periphery of
cheap labor and there's a periphery of
subsistence level resource extraction
and if if you're going with World
systems theory then like you look at
Vietnam and you're like well Vietnam was
about annexing or maintaining Vietnam as
part of the American economic supply
chain it didn't have to do with
containment Theory right right um and
like you're how your interpreting this
would fall in line with that of yeah
yeah no I'm not surprised I mean there's
a reason why I went down to Occupy Wall
Street and was interested in it I think
class-based issues are substantially
more important than race or or identity
based issues one of the problems we have
right now in the country is that the
left has adopted uh critical race Theory
which
it pits
people uh regular people against each
other poor people against each other you
end up with people like Serena Williams
who was one of the wealthiest people on
the planet most famous and and most uh
um celebrated and she's a victim and
she's oppressed and you'll get a
homeless white veteran who is an
oppressor now that system clearly does
not make sense class issues matter
substantially more than uh these you
know ridiculous ideas about privilege
now I certainly think racism exists
right I think the problem with the left
is they they're they see things too much
at the surface level White Privilege is
not what it is it's majority privilege
you know and any country in which you're
the majority you're going to have some
benefits because people think look and
act like you more so than than other
people immigrants or strangers but they
just say it's white privilege which is
extremely reductive when you have
someone who's white from South Africa or
a white person from Ukraine from from
Ukraine Luke gradkowski who comes on
who's on the show every so often he's a
blonde hair blue-eyed polish guy but
according to the critical race of the
artist he's a person of color
absolutely the the Coalition of
communities of color say that Slavic
people are people of color even if
they're white with blonde hair and blue
eyes no joke I'm English Scottish
Clydesdale I think the 23 meat test was
off oh then you're you're you're you're
white I'm straight up I'm just a jar of
mayonnaise I feel like you can reverse
engineer critical race Theory to look at
it as critical theory to see the class
structure rip their way because what
happened is when slavery ended in the
United States a bunch of people were
just descendants of slaves and slaves
were dumped onto the streets with no
education no money so their kids had no
education no money most of them then
their kids tend to have low or little
education of money and so we're looking
at like the Seventh Generation now a lot
of those families irrelevant of the skin
color they just happened to in this
iteration of slavery come from that area
redlining go on as well so which would
be the best way to accumulate
multi-generational wealth is home
ownership and that was basically
precluded up until 30 years ago 40 years
ago so now and you could argue there is
systemic racism in this but that it is a
class system yes but the economic
Fallout is the main fact
to introduce more complexity to what
we're talking about here it wasn't
necessarily just a straight line of this
group of people not gaining well through
the generations it's actually the case
that prior to the 1960s there were fewer
black out of wedlock births than there
are today by a significant margin and we
know one of the best ways to prevent
poverty is to ensure that you're married
before you have children and so
there are things that were done to the
black community some say the War on
Drugs some say the war on poverty The
Brookings Institute has actually said
legal abortion is a big part of it but
there are policies that came much later
yeah I I think there are I so I I think
systemic racism is is it absolutely
exists but there's there's a there's an
issue of
how the left interprets it what they
think it means and how far and extreme
they go with it so I'll give you an
example you'll talk to one of these
critical race theories about systemic
racism and they'll tell you today you
know that all police are racist or
whatever and I'm like okay you got to
stop you got to stop right the average
person is substantially less racist
leaning towards not even racist for the
most part these days that's the average
person you know but but that but they'll
tell you the whole system's racist well
the way I explain it to people is that
in the united in Chicago easus example
we had two big problems blockbusting and
redlining have you ever heard of these
redlining of course is very famous it's
where you have the red line trains these
the real estate companies would isolate
certain areas where they would only sell
to black people and they wouldn't sell
outside creating these you know
segregated areas blockbusting is one of
the dirtiest and most evil things you
know I've ever heard about it's where
these companies would go to a white
neighborhood buy a house move a black
family in and then go door to door to
all the houses and say there goes the
neighborhood you better sell to us
before it's too late the people would
Panic sell at a premium to the to these
companies who would then kick the black
family out and sell the whole
neighborhood back to white people at for
a profit that was made illegal redlining
was made illegal but only in the 80s
that means there are people my age today
who are just now the first generation
getting out of overtly nowadays illegal
systems that caused damage to People
based on their Race So what I could say
is yes obviously today remnants of that
racism still exists in the system are
individuals racist some still are but
for the most part we've done a lot to
change that the solution however is not
to go to a poor white person and say you
will not be granted access to this we
will take money from you that makes no
sense now that we've changed the laws
the solution is class based because if
the left believes that the black
community is disproportionately
impoverished then class-based issues
will still disproportionately favor them
but it won't leave behind Latinos Asians
or white people who are also negatively
impacted I I have an ex-girlfriend who
uh when we were dating her father lived
um I won't say where it is it's not out
her but her father if she wanted to call
him she couldn't because he didn't own a
phone she was white by the way so
where's your brother
um but like if she wanted to get in
contact with her dad she had to call her
neighbor and have her neighbor walk over
to get her dad because her dad was that
poor and I think that's a good example
of like I don't really feel like saying
he had massive privilege really counts
like like that that guy that couldn't
afford a phone I feel like is is
economically underprivileged and I'll
give you another example of um sister
systemic racism at work and government
that's still there when you look at
almost all zoning laws I am most
familiar with Los Angeles uh to plug it
I wrote a book called Los Angeles is
hideous poems about an ugly City so if
you don't like LA and you like funny
stuff it's a funny one I'll get your
copy timeline that sounds good it's fun
yeah I don't know it's it's just a
asphalt carbuncle uh but in the process
of researching these poems that I wrote
about Los Angeles
um the reason that Los Angeles is the
massive sprawling City that it is is not
uh it is accidental but it's not
unavoidable the reason that it's so
sprawling is that Los Angeles during the
I guess be the the 40s and 50s uh
basically like many cities in America
but I'm most familiar that way when uh
oh no black people are moving in we
should basically Outlaw apartment
buildings because the the it was racist
it was overtly racist at the time and
the thinking was well if we make people
live in homes and houses white people
can afford houses more than black people
can so already there's going to be an
advantage there but the way law is set
up in California is that houses in
certain neighborhoods have what are
called neighborhood covenants where you
own the property but if you have to sell
it the neighborhood itself has to write
off on that they have to sign off on
that meaning that they have to be a
morally upstanding person of our skin
color right and so that was intentional
so you look at like Los Angeles today 80
percent of the real estate in Los
Angeles now you can't have more than one
family living in a place you have to
have a house right even though it's like
what the second biggest the biggest city
in America you can't build up legally
you can't build up you have to build out
so it's pancaking
do you know the story of St Louis so St
Louis isn't actually one city it's I
think it's a 99 plus smaller
jurisdictions all cluttered together
really St Louis is a city don't get me
wrong but to the Greater St Louis area
that people refer to is actually a
collection of a whole bunch of small
cities and so uh what happened here was
a long long time ago in St Louis that we
we ended up with for a variety of
reasons desegregation comes into play
and there were many white people uh and
you got to understand that back in the
in the late 50s and 60s this country was
what like 92 90 or whatever percent
White
so you have you have these white
communities overtly white start seeing
black families moving into certain areas
and so they decide to start leaving what
they did was they moved outside of the
city and created their own communities
with Covenant with with the you know
covenants like you're only allowed to
have 10 houses in this city can't build
anymore to make sure no one else could
move in yeah long story short by today
we have 90 plus jurisdictions each with
their own Police Department what ends up
happening is that many of these areas
that are impoverished and there is a tie
between the black community and
historical poverty for a variety of
reasons like blockbusting red
blockbusting and redlining and we know
that homeownership is one of the ways
that people transfer wealth making it
very difficult for them
what happens is the system that is not I
wouldn't call a
today I wouldn't say it is racist but it
was created through racist ideas I mean
what we would call systemic racism right
like it's a great example of like those
of us with more like libertarian
inclinations can go great I don't like
regulations and this is a great example
of regulations being racist that we will
spending a night out and root them out
so what ends up happening is for racial
reasons we end up with all these
jurisdictions today and so I went down I
was in Ferguson during the Michael Brown
rights and uh I worked in a documentary
I produced a documentary about what was
going on there's something they have
called going on tour so what happens is
you are uh in one of these neighborhoods
that is predominantly black
you your your lower income for a variety
of reasons you have a vehicle and your
plate is expired now it's 20 bucks to
get your plate re-registered but you're
poor you've got in you know debt you've
got credit cards so you decide do I eat
do I pay gas or do I get my plate fixed
you say well look I gotta eat I gotta
pay my rent I can hope I don't get
pulled over for my plate
you drive from you so in order to go to
work you're likely going to drive
through two or three different cities
because they're these small
jurisdictions we saw this with a ton of
people they would leave their
neighborhood and while they're driving
they get pulled over and the cop says
your plates expired here's your ticket
have a nice day they start driving again
they get pulled over 10 minutes later
in a different jurisdiction and it keeps
happening then finally when they're like
I couldn't pay the 20 bucks I can't pay
the hundred yeah what happens is they'll
get arrested and it'll be like a two-day
thing you couldn't pay the fine it's two
days in jail yeah what happens when they
get out of jail the police from the next
jurisdiction are waiting for them to
take them to the next jail and they
might have lost their job during that
time and they and they usually did now a
lot of people say well they shouldn't be
driving with expired plates
perhaps that's true for a lot of these
people it's like yo I have to drive to
get to work I live in the suburbs but
another issue we we saw was people who
would get uh tickets for their their
headlight going out and so you're doing
you're driving you don't even know your
headlights out you get pulled over this
is one of the stories we heard and the
guys like so I say okay I'll go home I
gotta drive through two or three more
cities where I get pulled over and end
up with four tickets all for this do the
people that say like they shouldn't be
driving with expired Place why do we
have those like I get having a serial
number on your car that identifies you
own it makes sense to me you should have
that right but the little tags that's
just a regressive tax that all that's
all that is it doesn't do anything it's
like the reason we do that is because
poor people are the easiest group of
taxpayers to military against it's a lot
hardly try doing attacks on yoga and see
what happens to you you're not going to
get a bunch of upper middle class white
people that you do that here's what I
see it's like a cigarette taxes with a
lot of these people because of because
of past racism we see a disproportionate
amount of people who are impacted by a
lot of these policies being black yeah
the the left today even though we've
already passed laws outlawing all the
stuff and we have we have court
precedent outlawing it they look at
white people and they turn it into a
racism issue they can't let go I
certainly understand they were racist
white people who made racist laws right
but the challenge now is if we're going
to do away with racism
we can't have other people being racist
it does more racism doesn't stop racism
it's just making more racism that's why
I keep telling people the solution to
these problems is class based meaning if
your income level is at a certain rate
then we provide you with certain relief
because like I said if they genuinely
believe that systemic racism
disproportionately impoverished black
communities then a class-based solution
disproportionately benefits black
communities without leaving behind
Latinos Asians and you can have laws
which are colorblind which I think is a
lot of the reason we have so much animus
going on in the country right now is to
our great credit most Americans aren't
racist most Americans actually really
abhor the concept of racism and a lot of
the fight we're having right now is that
we have dueling definitions of racism so
I I would say and I think you guys are
probably on board with this that
attributing rights privileges or guilt
to someone based on skin color is
inherently racist so I don't want to do
that right but a lot of people would
disagree with this they would take more
of the equity approach so like we're
talking kind of about which is racist
yeah which is racist so we're going for
like equality of opportunity and we can
acknowledge that not everybody has the
same starting position and we need to be
trying to rectify that but but see
that's that's
um
it's a trick when they when that when
when these when these culty leftists
ideologues come out and say that um you
know I think you know we had to solve
this problem of racism with Equity they
don't really care about the issues of
racism they just know that people in
America don't like racism and they found
a way to exploit something that is
morally repugnant what they offer them
is I'm going to call you anti-racists
will you support that and the average
person says yes then they say okay be a
racist and support segregation and these
weak-willed people agree to it they
agree to we've got in Dearborn Michigan
we had the non the non-poc and the POC
segregated digital cafes up in you know
in Wisconsin we have the non-poc POC you
know Equity trainings in California they
actually tried to repeal their civil
rights legislation from their own
Constitution right so going to
California to its credit went wait a
minute you like just to be clearing this
the government's asking us if we want to
authorize giving right rights and
privileges based on skin color like
literally it's what the government was
doing
but they literally said we would like to
discriminate on the basis of race and
the Californian California people were
like yeah no we're not going to allow
that but it was close
so when they come out and they say we
oppose racism they're lying that's not
true they overtly support it we're the
the ability to disconnect anything like
I don't like this thing so I'm going to
declare its races so like I don't do
that I'll give you an example I don't I
think minimum wage is counterproductive
what I mean by that is I would love for
everybody to be making more money I'm
very much against poverty I think
minimum wage what you're really doing is
you're just outlawing labor below a
certain threshold which means if you're
not on the second rung of the ladder we
kick out the Bottom Rung of the ladder
and we go we fixed it with I don't think
that works right now I could go you know
the first folks in America that were
proponents of minimum wage were overt
white supremacists racists and they
literally said we don't want to have
white people having to compete with
black people this is them thinking black
people can always work for Less because
they have such low standards of living
so we've got to protect the white that
was racist right but I if you're today
if you're in favor of minimum wage I
think you were mistaken I don't think
you're doing it because you're a secret
wife all gun control is racist shout out
to Maj Toure black guns matter yeah he
makes a lot of really great points about
that and a lot of people really do need
to understand this even it was Adam you
ever see Adam ruins everything he had a
really great segment and I'm not I think
he gets a lot wrong but he talks about
how actually yeah gun control modern gun
control was racist basically the white
folks were afraid of the black folks
getting the Black Panthers yeah they
were they didn't like the idea and I
think it was Reagan it was California
and they were like we should have gun
control and it's funny because I get
these lefties these leftists overt
leftists who are like Tim Poole talks
about you know someone tweeted at me
because I said something like more guns
for everyone and someone responded
replied and they were like yeah but as
soon as the Black Panthers have guns you
start complaining and I responded with I
I want the Black Panthers to have all
the guns tell them to come by yeah yo
I'm like I was like I hope they get all
the guns in the world and then the
leftist responded based and what does
base mean I've seen this like on points
like correct oh okay you know Savvy by
the way you're 36 yeah I'm 38 and I you
where you at the relationship between us
right now like if we were in a mall
people would think you're my nephew
explaining Tick Tock to me you want and
it's all that College in your reading
you want to know oh yeah absolutely bio
trust thank you very much you know what
I would love to see I would love to see
you know you know we had that um what
was that Coalition in Georgia with all
it was it's the black Coalition nfac yes
nothing around yeah not effing around
Coalition I see it's you have you seen
this hundreds of guys marching through
Jordan uh through Georgia with guns
terrible Trigger Discipline terrible
yeah my only my only issue with them is
there was an accidental discharge more
than once I come on guys other than that
I'm like if you're gonna have a gun
parade you really can't accidentally
fire the game right my my credit is two
stuff my criticism these guys only had
one gun each they should have two
constitutional rights I'm not worried
about these guys hurting me I like that
they have guns and I think regular
people having guns is a good thing so
you want to talk about racism I think
gun control is overtly racist I'm not
surprised the Democrats have been the
ones pursuing it I think it was also a
little bit weird where the the country
for about four years was like guys we
are literally fascists we literally have
a fascist President we need to hide our
Jewish friends but also we should take
everybody's guns and give them to the
fascists I'm like wait a minute here
like if you actually thought a fascist
was in control of the like like you know
like January they're like Well we'd
never there'd never be a reason to have
an uprising uh nationally and I'm like
didn't the president contemplate like
you know basically sending in the
National Guard on January 6 and things
like I don't know I gotta say that's the
kind of thing that maybe we wouldn't
need to have guns left to Star pro-gun
Liberals are not like traditional
Liberals are not pro-gun they're
interesting yeah if you talk to any
socialist they're pro-program until they
gain power and then they'll probably
take the guns away from you but find
liberal too there's the American liberal
like you were saying a traditional
liberal economic order they kind of
Twisted the word yeah the traditional
liver is different liberal can I give
you my map of this because I I brought
on Adam gopnik from The New Yorker onto
the political orphanage he's a great guy
I really like Adam govnik right um I
think you could look at say like you you
can look at the Democratic Coalition and
broadly speaking it is a coalition of
leftists and liberals and the Republican
Coalition is a coalition of classical
liberals the the libertarian what we
would call the return generally and
social liberals uh and social
conservatives and and like growingly
like populist nationalists right you
look at the libertarian party that is a
coalition of classical liberals and
anarchists and the the interesting thing
is that like constitutional
conservatives are are intellectual
cousins with liberals but like leftists
or a completely different intellectual
lineage right like leftists are a whole
different ballpark whereas like uh I
don't know Mike Lee and Adam gopnick are
both coming out of that Adam Smith John
Locke they're coming out of the
Enlightenment right right it's like
Liberals are like they have that
Enlightenment background and the
distinction between liberals uh broad
Libertarians and conservatives tends to
be are we prioritizing like egalitarian
over meritocracy and are we like what
are we prioritizing but they're
operating that same space but yeah like
leftists are a completely different
ballpark is that the liberal economic
order like 1946 they start this that's
the that's the leftist No No I would say
like leftist like because like liberals
and again I'm using this like making I'm
getting real granular here right like
liberals as opposed to leftists are
believe in a market economy and rule of
law right like like they they're like
they're they're coming at they're
capitalists um the the difference is
that they're probably more bullish in
terms of the efficacy of government
regulation than say like you're average
conservative but like they're they're
kissing and cousins they're in the Saint
Paul Park right whereas like leftists
would be like no capitalism is
inherently exploitative like that like
like capitalism is a Bad Thing whereas
like uh liberals see government as
facilitating capitalism
yeah so it's interesting you know we try
to define the two umbrella factions in
the culture War they say left or right
within the right sphere of influence
it's amazing because of how vast and
wide reaching it is you've got the
politically homeless which are these are
these are not classical liberals you
know Dave Rubin likes to say you're a
classical liberal a classical liberal
and I think he means that colloquially
not uh in terms of the actual philosophy
of Classical liberalism I think maybe
not today but initially I thought he was
I I think what he was really referring
to is a liberal from like the 90s a 90s
Democrat of Bill Clinton or Donald Trump
and so a classical liberal to a lot of
people because I had this conversation
it's liberal comma classic like classic
Coke that's what he's referring to I
think nowadays he he more so understands
he talks about right libertarianism and
Classical liberalism Classical
liberalism like you're saying like lock
the enlightenment Etc civil
libertarianism but the politically
homeless we see a lot of these people
are social liberals which is a
center-left Libertarian position which
is where I am a little bit and that's
where I can say things like I believe
they're systemic racism I just think the
leftist cult of you know people very
much against censorship right like like
oh go ahead so I I we also got to make
sure we're talking about the Nuance here
um I'm opposed to censorship in terms of
political opinions yeah political
discourse coercive government for
suppressing but there's a big challenge
there some people have opinions which
border on well I'll put it this way
you're allowed to have the opinion to
say the opinion but censorship can be
good
yeah you don't think so
um I I I'm pulling you into a trap by
the way sure okay so can we make a
distinction here too there's a
difference between cultural censorship
and government censorship I'm going to
say with government censorship
um to the extent that you are
suppressing a willful active call for
violence in the sense that like if I
tried to literally have people come kill
you that would be something you're not
expressing an opinion you're you're just
precipitating a crime what about content
huh uh and if you're if it's you I think
as far as the government is concerned
you have ultimate freedom of expression
and ultimate freedom of opinion any
opinion you have is legally valid uh the
government should never suppress your
opinion now now that's different than a
culture right a culture is a little bit
more different because cultures like
well maybe I don't want to have you on
my platform because I just don't like
you right or maybe it's bad for my
bottom dollar I give you a really good
example and it's a uh thanks to our good
friend Ian helping who who's in light
meal the graphite
um Ian was a sensor yeah I worked at
mines and compounded mines and did
administrative stuff for five years
right but it's not any government
censorship right like that's a private
private no no no no no no no no no no no
no it's a combination of cultural and
government when people are posting
graphic images of children and sexual
positions
sensors are extremely important it's
illegal so that's government the
government sets up the legalities and
then the culture kind of begins then
they set their own terms so like Twitter
can ban you for things that aren't
illegal technically they can all ban you
for any reason without for no reason at
all uh which is crazy but none of that
would run afoul of my criteria that I
established of expressing an opinion but
so I would imagine posting it about
whether child pornography should be
legal or not like when people post a
picture of something saying this is my
opinion the picture says it all that's
not really someone's opinion you're
writing text on a page that's not really
your opinion that's text my point was
just simply I think when a lot of people
say censorship there's a sort of
colloquial definition that is a narrow
view of what censorship is and that is
someone expressing their opinion uh
having a discussion and they get shut
down by one of these platforms and uh
yeah we agree but you could say my I
think the child porn should be legal
that I don't think
obviously no you can say that that is
legal to say you're allowed to have a
loud opinion yeah you can say that on
social media
right because it's illegal so isn't that
also but here's what isn't that is that
not also a call to violence to take that
position because you're saying this
inherently violent thing should be
allowed to be done to Children what do
you mean you're allowed to say that in
the United States no no no it's not an
imminent flight violence if it was
imminent if you were like on Thursday at
2PM you should fill in the blank then
you're that's illegal I think I think if
you were to take that logic to it to the
nth degree if if you think a zygote is a
child then you would be able to suppress
pro-choice rhetoric because it would be
killing children right yeah I mean I and
I do believe as I go it's a child I
think that if someone's speaking uh
pro-choice talking points it makes sense
to have an argument especially because a
lot of people aren't as informed on the
science there but when it comes to
directly saying that people should be
able to do things that directly harm
children but if I was if I was an
abortion doctor and I said I think we
should have abortions right and your
worldview I would be saying we should be
killing babies yeah absolutely should my
opinion be legally suppressed that's a
really good question I think there's a
difference that's actually a really good
question I'm going to think about that
but I think there's a difference between
that and arguing in favor of CP no like
if you're actually pushing to legalize
it when it's not already legal correct
we're pushing to legalize something
that's already illegal well you're
allowed
yeah but if you say do it and you
there's an imminent yeah can I can I
back up a little bit because I want to
talk about the culture word briefly yeah
um I I think that it is a complete
misnomer to even discuss the culture war
in terms of less birth left versus right
I think that this is a trick that
corporate media does because it knows it
can get people fired up because we have
been taught to embrace what I call
teeter-totter thinking teeter-totter
thinking is if I say something negative
about Biden I must be pro-trump right if
I say something negative about Obama I
must be pro-george W bush sometimes they
all suck right shout out to Michael
malice you know when when he tweets
something bad about Biden they're alive
our Anarchist friend right who thinks
all government is illegitimate is not a
fan but I just love it when people tweet
at him he'll say something about Biden
and they'll be like well Trump did this
and he's like okay right again it's not
a teeter-totter you can have but but
like but but the it's easier to make
money by getting people to go on red
versus blue all the time right the
culture war is not right versus left
it's never been right versus left the
culture war is between pluralists and
authoritarians um it's we've we've had
so many conversations trying to to to to
you know assess and break down the
culture War I do think left and right
are just terms we use socially to
describe parent factions like leftists
and traditional liberals for some reason
are aligned it's very strange and then
you have social liberals Libertarians
and social conservatives aligned very
strange like Dave Rubin a gay married
man hanging out with uh you know a
conservative Jewish man Ben Shapiro and
uh they're because they're they agree on
more important things than certain
issues that have been you know
overshadowed by the culture I'll argue
that the left oh please I was going to
say you said pluralists versus
authoritarian yeah
um I I actually think it's uh it's
really hard to Define we've we've looked
at it a few ways a lot of people have
said authoritarian versus libertarian
thinking you know we're hearing I think
that would be a good stand and although
others use different terms but there's
also a lot else in there we had Stephen
Marsh on the show who wrote the book the
next civil war and he said within the
United States there is a multicultural
democracy and a constitutional republic
and they can't co-exist and that's
really interesting too because you could
say that the left culture War faction is
a multicultural democracy in the right
as a constitutional republic and that
actually explains the disparate
political opinions better than left or
right yeah elaborate on that because
well so you look at someone like Dave
Rubin a gay married man and Ben Shapiro
and they get along and it's because
they're in the constitutional republic
they look at America and its values and
though they disagree on social issues
their their core fabric is is well
within a framework they understand the
Multicultural democracy doesn't believe
in things like republicanism you know
electoral college is a really good
example of this they want majority rules
they want uh open borders Multicultural
thinking and that may be an easy way to
explain it there is another way that
I've explained it too the
judeo-christian moral framework versus
the fascistic moral framework how we
would describe the left is to quote the
late David Graber they've adopted tenets
of fascism that there is no truth but
Power whereas the constitutional
republic believes in inalienable rights
and a lot of values that are rooted in a
Christian moral framework whether they
realize it or not for example uh the the
right to your innocent until proven
guilty is it actually comes from the
Bible so I I was fascinated by this and
I read the history of I believe this is
this is the Fifth Amendment right
um has a couple other couple Provisions
in it but um I was reading about why is
it that in the United States we take
very seriously you are innocent until
proven guilty well it actually comes
from a quote from Ben Franklin is better
than 100 guilty persons Escape than one
is in person suffer that value came to
him through blackstone's formulation it
is better that 10 guilty persons Escape
than once in person suffer and
blackstone's formulation is based on on
the story of Sodom and Gomorrah if there
is but one righteous person you know I
will not destroy the city and then I
think ultimately God does you know his
wife but only after he evacuates it
evacuates the people and so
people like Bill Maher I find
interesting because he's secular he's an
atheist but his moral values are built
upon a Christian moral framework whether
he realizes it or not I'm not saying he
has to believe in God or he does because
of this I'm saying the values that were
that were born out of Christianity he
retains those despite not believing in
the actual religion the leftists don't
believe in that religion at all and they
have no core moral framework which is
probably why they flip-flop on issues
and there seems to be no cohesive moral
pattern to what they do it's why they
will defend some it's why they'll say
only white people can be racist and
Candace Owens is a white supremacist
right there's no clear logical pattern
there because there is no root moral
framework other than there is no truth
but Power which is what David Graber
said he said this a few years ago he was
the he didn't like being called this but
they called him the anarchist
Anthropologist and he said that the left
a certain sect to the left has embraced
fascistic tenants
can I outline outline my theory for you
just convolute this a little bit more
um so as I said I see it like like I
know you brought up on the show before
the political Compass right so like the
X Y axis of like economic versus social
left libertarian and so on so forth I
would posit there's a separate axis
which is how do you react to negative
opinions or how should Society govern
negative opinions and if you're coming
towards the top of that you're on the
side of pluralism which is to say like
Dave Rubin and Ben who I think are a
good example of this I disagree with you
but our society is big enough for people
I disagree with we're not going to crack
down on that error is okay within a
pluralistic society you're allowed to be
wrong I'm an atheist you guys are
Catholics or whatever the thing is right
we can do that right if you're not a
pluralist you're an authoritarian your
line of thinking is no Society has to be
on the same page and I think there's a
spectrum to it I think that like I think
that the people that are authoritarians
tend to be they self-soothe through
compliance where when when there's a
pandemic it's very important to March
around and go you've got to wear your
mask right now uh because I I am going
to self-soothe myself by doing this or
alternately
um you you can never ever say that
whatever the thing is you can't say that
so one of the things too uh in all this
to you know to build upon this
uh for the Constitutional public faction
or whatever you want to call it it seems
like we all believe in something greater
than ourselves when I say that Sheamus
has rights it's because I believe that I
am not
God I am not an all-powerful entity I am
not deserving of this world war entitled
I believe that an individual has equal
rights to me because there is something
that exists outside of me that I don't
control we are all within this one
Universe I don't necessarily think
that's um inherently rooted in
Christianity it's rooted in an idea that
the universe is bigger than you but you
look at what the the modern you know
left tribe or Multicultural democracy
view is and it's if I can take the power
I should and so it seems like their
moral framework is not built upon
whether or not another person has
individual rights which is why once
again there seems to be no logic to
whatever morality they claim to have it
seems like they're willing to just say
what they need to say to gain power
which is why you end up with Instagram
accounts or Twitter accounts like
defiant LS were you very very often will
get a treat from a mainstream left
personality saying you know we should do
X and then uh you know a tweet from them
later saying you know X is evil you'll
get people saying uh you know war is
wrong or Donald Trump is going to lead
us into World War III is a madman and we
need to impeach him and then Joe Biden
absolutely should be implementing a
no-fly zone even if it starts world war
three there's no logical consistency
there other than if I if it gains me
power I can do it my world view is I
have no right to usurp power from other
people by force or through manipulation
because there is something bigger than
me right well I since we're fans of
convoluting things I want to convolute
this even first I'll go after you so
when it comes to this idea of a
political compass and the culture or
part of work gets really confusing is
that it seems to me as if right now for
the past several years it has more or
less been the case that at least when it
comes to many social and economic issues
the left is more authoritary and the
right tends towards something a little
more libertarian but not necessarily
fully libertarian but it seems as if
whichever group on the right or left has
power will become more authoritarian and
so it's something that each side will
jump to and from and also what a person
views as being authoritarian or
non-authoritarian is totally informed by
whether they're on the right or left so
for example when you're talking about
the masks and the vaccines and these
other coveted lockdowns someone on the
left is going to say well that's not
authoritarian at all I'm actually
protecting the little guy uh or if you
look at even something like economic
issues they'll say well by increasing
taxes on large corporations I'm not
telling people are voluntarily
exchanging goods that they're not
allowed to do that and acting as an
authority I'm actually protecting the
little guy because he doesn't have as
much leverage so for me it's difficult
to separate the left and right from
authoritarianism slash libertarianism
but also it's difficult for me to Define
exactly where they're connected but let
me just say
there's a reason why when you look at
polls Independence and moderates tend to
have similar World World Views to
conservatives it's very very simple who
would you say is uh the most prominent
Progressive left personality you'll see
and in terms of like media punditry not
politics oh uh in terms of gosh I don't
know uh in terms of anybody have any
Talking Heads yeah say let's say someone
with Stephen Colbert Stephen Colbert
he's like an astonishment liberal though
I wouldn't that's fine I thought we were
talking about yeah so uh let me ask you
a question if you were sitting down and
you had Stephen Colbert on one side and
Ben shapir on the other who do you think
would tell you the truth and nothing but
the truth
you know I actually really like Colbert
I don't think he'd lie to me I I
disagree with his politics I do think
he's a decent man so he lies
he lies a lot tell you what could we I
never lie Fox okay I've never liked and
I would not lie to Stephen I I I uh I've
I disagree with Ben Shapiro's politics
you know not all of them but uh when I
watch him argue I'm like well what he's
saying is true I I see his assessment
there I'll disagree with him I see I've
seen him be wrong but I have I have seen
mainstream left personalities outright
lie every step of the way I mean I run
the list I think every day this week
I've run the list on all the mainstream
not all of them as many as I can count
on one hand it's so easy to do I I have
to put on my Pollyanna hat for a minute
I I don't think that there is a
political ideology in the United States
that is just inherently prone to lying
or immorality I think most of the people
in the United States be the on the left
the right the center independent
whatever most people are wanting to live
in a free prosperous peaceful society
and the argument is how we achieve that
should I start counting
but but but I just gotta say I think
you're completely wrong Trayvon Martin's
story was a lie the mainstream he was
NBC I believe edited the phone call from
Zimmerman to make it sound like he was
racist the Michael Brown story was a lie
his hands were not up hands up don't she
was not shoot is not true Jessie
Smollett obviously do you think that's
the institutions that are lying or do
you think there's people prone to the
left are liars like do you think it's
something inherent to the political
philosophy or do you yes there is no
truth but power so we've seen this
rising over the past decade or so and
that's that's why I cite David Graber
because he was the anarchist
Anthropologist he was a left Anarchist
who who tweeted this out that they have
adopted this tenet of there is no truth
but power so you can actually see them
come out and and overtly lie every step
of the way and it's not just the
activists who are now being indicted on
fraud on more than one occasion or the
BLM offices which apparently didn't
exist and no one was there and the money
is who knows where the woman who's got
multiple houses or the women in Boston
who's being indicted on 18 charges of
fraud don't get me wrong the right has
their lives and manipulators because
grifters and con men and con women exist
across the board but when you have cons
consistently russiagate's fake Ukraine
gate is fake the Covington kids thing
was a hoax the uh um Cal Rittenhouse
story fabricated the left was actually
putting up stories saying he crossed
eight lines of the gun to hunt down
black people which was totally
fabricated you can go through almost
every single story about some hate some
graffiti vandals and hate crime and it
was a tweet between Matt Walsh and Matt
Walsh put up with him and Andy know and
they said I can't think of any example
in recent history in which this turned
out to be true where a white supremacist
person was racist and sprayed a swastika
or a slur it always turns out to be a
hoax across the board
Ahmed arbory is one that really really
gets me because the conservatives bought
into it too you know the story the guy
was jogging they said and then the three
white guys lynched him or something
versus the guy that got shot the jogger
that like well he wasn't jogging but
sure uh yeah so he ran up to the truck
where the two guys were and then tried
to take the shotgun from one of the guys
and then it went off and hit him in the
chest and he was a felony burglary a
suspect look the guy shouldn't have died
but when you get even conservatives like
Fox News coming out and just playing
along with the establishment's lies over
and over and over again you got a
problem but yeah I just got to say if I
talk to Ben Shapiro he might be wrong
about some things but he tries to be
factual and that's not I'm not saying
Ben Shapiro is a perfect human being I'm
sure he gets things wrong I'm sure
there's things he can't talk about but I
keep seeing this as a tendency there it
is the it is the uh on the right the
rule is typically honest and the
exception is sometimes people lie or get
things wrong on the left the rule is
they lie all the time and the exception
is some of them sometimes are honest
crystal ball is a progressive she's
fantastic Jimmy Dore is a leftist he's
fantastic Kyle Kolinski also fantastic I
think Moses we do we do differ on that
and that and I'm not I'm not saying gay
left but I I think it's dangerous to
live in a manichaean world of my team's
the good team and we're the holy people
they're not my team I'm not a
conservative sure but the reality
there's like black hats and white has
like one of the things things I noticed
in politics of late is there is a view
of the problem is bad people and then
the other system is the problem is bad
systems I'm a system thinker right so I
think that if you take a bad system you
put in good people you're still going to
get Negative outcome
um I don't think that if you just root
out all the bad people all of a sudden
everything works well right so I'm very
bothered by the increase in manikey and
thinking in the United States and the
idea that there's a bad team and a good
team if we could just go feed the bad
team well so what if the bad team is the
institutions and the establishment and
another one will rise up if you burnt
right I think they're separate I don't
feel that rule I don't think within the
American context that like liberals the
atom got mix we're talking about earlier
I don't think that they're inherently
Liars or anything like that I'll give
you I'll give you a hard example
um the Gordon Sandlin testimony over
Trump and quid pro quo there's a there's
an image I have on my Instagram showing
two TV screens I think one is CBS and
one is Fox News one is overtly lying and
one is closer to the truth Fox News as
it turns out CBS says sondling confirms
quid pro quo why well Sandlin was asked
did Donald Trump engage in a quid pro
quo and he said well Trump told me
explicitly I don't want anything for
this no quid pro quo
think he wanted it so CBS reports
confirmed he wanted it why because some
guy's opinion wasn't Fox News went with
the factual statement which is Trump
said no quid pro quo and sandlin's
opinion is not relevant to what the
president actually requested now when
you have those two screens showing the
exact opposites and one is based on the
opinion of a guy irrespective of the
fact that Trump said no quid pro quo
that is a lie now it's an anecdotal lie
it doesn't necessarily make it
emblematic and at a certain point you
have almost every single black lives
matter major story that resulted in Mass
writing the defense of the mass Riders
every single life on the mainstream
media mostly peaceful protests while the
police department's burning down at a
certain point if you say these people
aren't inherently bad people then I
think you're actually running defense
for people who have been proven time and
time again to lie about everything so
let me let me just do I have to say like
if I've got a neighbor that's a Democrat
do I have to say he's an inherently bad
person no of course not okay the average
Democrat voter is probably just not
aware of a lot of these issues and the
bigger issue is that organizations like
The Daily Beast for instance lie about
everything but when you see just the
other day the New York Times finally
acknowledged that the hunter Biden's
laptop was real NPR said not a real
story Facebook and Twitter used this
reporting from mainstream Outlets to
suppress factual information that was
very very pertinent to this election
that was coming up they do this all the
time and when you see these activist
organizations on the left working in
tandem with them at a certain point you
have to be like yo they're all in
alignment they're consistently lying to
us and they're destroying and harming
people every time they do this Kamala
Harris helped bail out people who are
riding and burning down buildings Joe
Biden launched his campaign on a lie
claiming that Donald Trump defended
white supremacists which he didn't do
the media just lied about everything
over and over and over again now Fox
News is not perfect Hannity is is very
much a war Monger I'm not a big fan of
Hannah or Ingram I think Tucker is
actually a bit he takes things a little
far against the language sometimes Fox
news's basic reporting like Brett Bear
it's actually not that bad and if you
watch the five Geraldo Rivera may as
well be a Democrat they've got a good a
group of voices kind of arguing with
each other but you turn on uh CNN or
MSNBC and I'm sitting there just like
wow it's all lies it's just over and
over again take a look at this just
recently The Daily Beast claimed that I
pushed Kremlin propaganda about U.S
funded bio weapons Labs literally I've
never said that in fact the segments
we've done in the show is me saying this
story is probably not true they're not
bio weapons Labs these Maps don't even
line up yet they just fabricate the
information the amount of fake stories
that were the amount of stories that
were fabricated by The Daily Beast about
me are are absolutely ins it's insane to
watch but look outside of me outside of
anecdotes if you have 800 or a thousand
anecdotes of all of these throughout for
the past dozen you know a dozen or so
years they've all kept doing the same
thing at a certain point you have to say
I think this might be data right so you
start with the beginning of black lives
matter Trayvon Martin fabricated story
Zimmerman's not a white guy he's
hispanic he didn't just walk up to
Trayvon and kill him they were actually
fighting Trayvon was Adam on the ground
terrifying question
when you say that you have all this data
clearly you do is this data going into a
binary framework like is it the right
the left and everybody's on that do you
think there's multiple like for me I
look at I think there's like 15
different political tribes in the United
States and we falsely lumped them into
left versus right and that lends itself
to this mannequin thinking of good
versus bad blue versus red everybody's
in one or the other like there's paint
your worldview format there's two parent
spheres of influence what we could
describe as the left sphere of influence
and the right sphere of influence within
each of these are other disparate
factions often they don't even agree
with each other progressives very much
don't like the establishment Democrats
but they're in the same sphere of
influence based upon the news they
consume their tendency towards lying uh
and what you know and how they're
willing to manipulate to gain power uh
on the right sphere of influence you
have a sort of value you and moral honor
based system that credibility is earned
through being honest with someone
allowing them to fact check it and then
making your case what was the left one
again the left sphere of influence
like the traditional Democrats the media
sure I mean like you said the right is
like moral and honor based what was the
level the left is fascistic
um and I'm not saying they're fascists
I'm saying they use the they adhere to
the tenant of there's no truth but Power
which is literally what black lives
matter and critical race there is
activists actually I mean so you do I
mean this is something we disagree on
you do have a fairly mannequined
worldview there's there's the good
people and there's the bad people I
didn't say anybody was good or bad okay
well I mean it's honor-based and moral
based sounds like the good people to me
if I if I didn't know what the terms I
didn't say I didn't say good morals I
said the right tries to win over people
by proving how good good of people they
are and how respectful I don't agree
with that I think they would make fun of
people and try and try and browbeat
people into being there everybody does
that everybody okay what I'm saying is
when you look to like a Ben Shapiro his
his method of influence is here's the
facts
and I'm being honest with you about the
facts now here's my argument as to why
my world view is correct and my opinions
are right and my policy are the answer
you can agree with it I disagree with
that the left disagrees with that if you
agree with that then you are more in
tune with a lot of the right sphere of
influence the left believes there is no
truth but Power they literally will tell
you this they write it in their books
David Graber pointed it out they will
say by any means necessary which is
actually the name of an organization
that engages in overt acts of violence
to gain power they will come to you and
they believe they have a right to lie to
you if the if the end if the means are
worth it so what will happen is you'll
get someone who will come out like Jared
Holt who I've been really ragged on
because he wrote this fake story about
me and he'll say Tim Poole was pushing
kremlin-backed propaganda about U.S bio
weapons and Shady labs in Ukraine now
it's not true he knows it's not true
because he showed a clip from the show
where we said it was not true so why
would he lie because this is in line
with exactly what David Graber and many
other people have pointed out that the
left operates under the tenant there's
no truth but Power it's a it's it's
fascistic but it's very much in line
with you know the blank slate ideology
or social constructivism or whatever
they believe that if they just create
Reality by saying things then they can
ultimate if they can just say lies to
formulate a base reality then ultimately
the systems they want will start to
exist the right says it's it's sort of
like this in the right sphere of
influence here's what is and here's my
argument about it and the left is I will
tell you whatever I need to tell you to
convince you to to follow my lead so
I've got a a different map mine is not
binary
um mine is multiple Venn diagrams and
kind of multiple almost like different
species right there's different genuses
that are coming out
um like I I don't like binary thinking
and I think applying it to politics is
too reductive and I'll give you kind of
a parallel example go back to religion
right like if we had a world view of all
religions the Protestant or Catholic
that would be incoherently reductive
like if you went what are you I'm a Jew
oh okay well if you're could you say
there's secular there's there's atheists
and there's theists
that's a way to look at it yeah but like
again like if you're saying one
component of the big picture of religion
well I mean like let's let's bring up
Buddhists I mean Buddhists are are God
does not apply either way in Buddhism
you could be you could be a theist and a
Buddhist you could be an atheist and a
Buddhist right so like but but like if
you were to say like you're a Jew okay
well in the in the Catholic versus
Protestant world that we live in you're
very Catholic about tradition but you're
very Protestant about people
infallibility it's like no it's a
separate thing it's a different
phenomenon are you like like classical
Liberals are different than European
conservatives of the blood and soil
variant which are different than
leftists but we're talking about the
United States and the the the the the
media the the the the parents spheres of
influence and their underlying I think I
think there's clearly two major parties
you know there's truly illegal electoral
blocks but they're basically illusionary
that there's a top-down construct that's
being placed on what are actually lots
of different tribes of people I don't
know eight and ten whatever it is right
this is exactly what I'm saying it
sounds to me though that you've got like
a fun fundamental DNA to both that
there's like one group has like a
Wellspring of Might verse might is right
and fascism or fascistic thinking and
the other one is honored and moral based
they all kind of spring from that so
they're they're sort of two broad
species those are just Tendencies of the
parent factions right obviously within
the right sphere of influence you
actually have social liberals who will
argue systemic racism or things that
I've said that clearly people like you
know conservatives might argue against
we don't all completely agree on
everything but you take a look at um you
know there's a really there's a really
simple way you know to break it down
well I should say there's there's
probably not we try to find different
ways to understand what these two
spheres of influence are because they
clearly exist you know clearly Jimmy
Dore is called he's called right wing
even though he's socialist and it's
confusing people call me a conservative
even though I'm like pro-progressive tax
pro-choice and think systemic racism is
bad because left and right signify that
you are in line with a certain world
view and I think it's one easy way maybe
to understand it is in the right sphere
of influence or whatever you want to
call it there are people who say prove
it
and the left sphere of influence there
are people who say tell me what to think
yeah I I refuse to be put on a spectrum
defined by dead Frenchmen like the whole
left versus right thing like I I but I
think you're looking too much into it
just because the French Revolution
created this concept of left and right
doesn't mean that our use of a word to
describe a concept is is not you know
relevant to to however you were saying
the people on the right say prove it and
the people on the left are like tell me
what to think but what about religion I
think the people on the right tend to be
the ones that are religious yeah
as Peter pogosian argued the the woke
intersectionality critical race theory
is a is a uh non-theistical God
Christianity Judaism people on the right
conservative people where's okay they
don't need proof for that they believe
it's just a hand value too I I think I
see this is a the human mind we're
actually talking about this earlier
because uh I was playing some Dido music
because Sheamus and I were working on
this bit and uh it auto played uh one of
us by it wasn't named Joan Osborne you
know what if God was one of us and I
remember when I was little they said
there was like a controversy around it
and I asked Sheamus if this song was a
fence or whatever I have no idea he's
like I've never I've never really hurt
well no I I don't know the lyrics I
don't know but but uh you know what came
up was me saying like
I keep hearing uh I'll give you I'll
give you an example there's a meme and
it shows a guide to Podium yelling to a
bunch of people how many of you think
abortion is should be banned and they're
all like yay and they said how many of
you think adoption is better than
abortion they all cheer and then he says
how many of you are willing to adopt and
all the people are sad like and I think
that's fascinating because when when I
actually will you know read articles or
read about pro-life organizations turns
out they adopt like crazy turns out the
people who are pro-life actually do
adopt and do donate and do try to help
kids so why is it that these uh these
Democrat voters or pro-choice
individuals believe that pro-lifers are
out there in front of ban abortion
without supporting adoption which is
just fundamentally false it's because
once again it falls back into the Trope
of activists who want something when it
applies to the left sphere of influence
are willing to lie to you to convince
you they're moral morally just or right
whereas the right doesn't do that uh
another there's another thing to point
out in this as to why it might be the
case Jack Dorsey said this when I was on
with Rogan he said conservative
journalists follow liberal journalists
and conservative journalists liberal
journalists only follow liberal
journalists it's entirely possible that
they're making up their view of
conservatives in their own mind I do
think that's true like so something that
I've noticed the last few years I'm
gonna I'm gonna we're gonna reproach now
um I do think that in the American
context generally speaking if a
conservative actually I'm going to add
this conservative libertarian and and
liberal although libertarian
conservative more similar to each other
if if a conservative disagrees with you
they think you're crazy if a Libertarian
disagrees with you they tend to think
you're ill-informed but it's kind of
similar to failure of information right
if a progressive disagrees with you they
think you're evil yes uh I I thought
about this really hard I think that it's
structural I don't think that it's
innate like I talked to Jonathan Roche
who wrote the the constitution of
knowledge about this recently his theory
is that human beings are innately tribal
we innately castigate the other as
morally defective whereas our group is
uh nuanced and good right so I think
what's happening is
um me being from Oklahoma I'm from the
middle most of my family's conservative
most of my friends are conservative
um being in the middle they're consuming
content from the coasts all the time so
they know that they really like Tom
Hanks or George Clooney or whoever they
know he's a Democrat but they like him
so they can they can sustain a world
view of I like this person but I
disagree with them but I don't think
that's happening with Progressive media
as much because they're not going to
church or Nascar or whatever the thing
is they're not they're not they're not
going to Nashville for country music so
they don't have media they're regularly
consuming of counter examples of someone
that I disagree with who I like and so
they're able to facilitate these cartoon
characters of mustache twirling evil
capitalists why do they want to get
Tucker Carson Carlson pulled off the air
well we can we can speculate all day and
night I would argue it's because Tucker
Carlson is a conservative who has
conservative voices on his show and he
regularly invites the left on to debate
and they do
there's a reason why many of the people
on the left who spread lies all day
won't come on this show because we would
show that they're lying I'm from Chicago
I grew up in a city run by democrats for
80 years I grew up with leftists is it
working in Chicago yeah absolutely not
oh okay and so what's fascinating is I
got called conservative because I said
Democrats suck and I said oh yeah I
think Republicans suck too but perhaps
it's that growing up in a city that's
been run by democrats for 80 years you
really get mad at this overtly corrupt
group that's been lying to you and is
just has been BSG the whole way but I
will say when I was younger I voted for
I voted for Obama I was very much I went
out vote and we could vote Democrat
across the board and I was I was totally
in line with all of that thinking and
then as I started to move out and travel
around the world and actually meet
people and start reading what people
were saying I said hey wait a minute
when they claimed conservatives were
outraged about that
I talk to conservatives and that's not
true a good example is um I would I I
hung out with a bunch of uh atheists
secularists and they would make a bunch
of arguments about Christianity and what
conservatives believed and then I would
be like yeah and then I'd go talk to a
conservative and they would be able to a
Christian conservative and they'd be
able to give me answers and actually
explain their ideas and I go oh those
people were lying to me about what you
thought or at least didn't know right
and so what ends up happening is I work
for vice I work for an ABC company ABC
Univision and then uh I actually see how
evil these people are you know uh when I
worked for Fusion this is an ABC
Innovation company the president told me
side with the audience and I said does
that mean if there's a factual news
story that would be offensive to our
audience we don't report it he says I
think that's fair yeah like they
outright say look our audience are young
and Progressive so we're going to take
their side take their side I'm like
here's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
report what happened and that's what
that's about what I can do I'm not going
to frame it or side with them siding
with them means if I go to a rally and I
watch a fight breakout between a trump
supporter and antifa and antifa started
it I got a side with antifung say it's a
trump supporter's fault no I won't do
that I'll say the antifa guy threw the
brick first Trump got started fighting
and that tends to be what happens they
don't like it they call me a liar I've
been doing this for some time I got
started with the hacker Community which
got me more involved I used to work for
non-profits I I was very much involved
with a lot of hacker Community stuff and
um
then it leads me into the underground on
the ground at Occupy Wall Street and
then it's really really simple I've
never been a conservative I'm still not
a conservative if anything I'm I'm a
Libertarian Centrist leaning slightly
left and I read the news all day every
day and at a certain point it becomes
fairly obvious The Establishment lies
and has lied my entire life to get us
into war and for power they've been
exploiting leftist ideals because it's
an easy way to get youth to pitch in and
give them their power the media and the
left all have embraced lying to gain
power and then I look at you know uh
prominent conservative media and they
have a tendency to get the story correct
so it's a tent so that's why I say on
the right with all these Outlets I can
pull these things up and then run a fact
check surprise surprise this is why they
call Matt taibi right wing right so I I
find that I am Center whatever you're
not whenever I'm talking to anybody all
my Democrat friends think I'm center
right by which they mean I'm a
conservative because I'm not whatever
they are but I'm palatable that's what
Center means but when I talk to my
conservative friends they think I'm
Center left like but which I take on my
end I take to think that the system that
they're using that spectral thinking is
too reductive right but I find that I'm
always the center version of what the
person I'm talking to is not well it's
because you're to the left of someone on
the right to the right of someone on the
left
could be yeah one one interesting way to
look at it is uh in a physical sense or
actually another thing I'll add to that
because I do think I'm not trying to
fight with you Tim I'm just trying to
understand where we come from um I I
have a uh I have uh just kind of I think
by virtue of the fact that I'm from
Oklahoma and I I have all these
conservative friends and I lived in New
York and I have all these liberal
friends that I I recoil from villain
based thinking and so I tend to go to
systemic thinking right what what about
but I think it's part of the reason
people get mad at me is you're not doing
this right now but a lot of the time
when other people are like hey how come
you don't hate this other thing because
I don't like hating I'm confused though
what about how I described either group
would make any of them a villain
they sound rather villainous when you
describe that's your moral values not
mine okay if if the left says overtly
and they do there is no truth but Power
when they write books saying truth is a
social construct two plus two equals
five I'm not making that up or assigning
moral value to whether or not they're
doing something right or wrong you are
if you say that sound villain it sounds
villainous that's your morals
do you think it's villainous I think
because you said they were evil a minute
ago I mean it sure sounds like you're
attributing I I think that uh well when
I describe the group I didn't say well
you've got good people and evil people I
said no the right tries to stand on a
moral ground like they're Standing Tall
with their chest out saying I'm gonna be
honest and and be respectful of you and
prove to you why I'm a good leader and
the left says two plus two equals five
it's right get in line if you heard of a
guy named Eric Grossman because he he I
think he'd be interesting to check out
um he's not saying what you're saying
but it's sort of uh adjacent to what
you're saying so the theory he has is
that and Trump is a big exception to
this but basically over the last 50
years that the Republicans uh both
organize and
a think ideologically or think in terms
of abstract values right hence the
fights in Republican primaries tend to
be who's the real Republican who's the
real conservative who's the Rhino right
right and then when you think about when
you think about like if we were going to
break down the Republican party it would
be ideological right it would be well
here are your neocons here are your
Libertarians here are your social
conservatives
Etc right Democrats organize and think
coalitionally so Democrats when you look
at how they organize they're not really
looking at it as progressives versus
Centrist they're looking at it like well
we've got the union we've got
um you know we've got Latin Americans
we've got gays we've got all these
they're thinking in terms of the
component structure right I think a lot
of crosstalk happens because when
progressives look at conservatives
because they think coalitionally they
see conservatives and go well all this
ideological stuff has to be a smoke
screen you're really just in it for the
white guy which is not true they're
ideological I think a lot of the time
conservatives do that when they look at
progressives where they go because we
think ideologically you guys must be
lying to us and you might must truly be
mo you must be secretly reading Marxist
literature and stuff whereas like I
don't think Biden is that ideological I
think that he's he's thinking in terms
of unions he's thinking in terms of all
these things but I don't think he's an
idea I I I got to be honest I think you
don't know enough about Joe Biden
like you weren't aware that he was
sharing bank accounts with his son I
think when you when you look at all of
the stories over the past you know seven
years related to his family and the the
illicit dealings he had to assume that
Joe Biden is thinking in terms of the
working class is completely out of line
with the reported character that is I'm
not making a character statement I'm
just saying in terms of how he thinks
like
um an ideologue isn't somebody who's
like I have a theory I'm really
philosophical that kind of thing I don't
think he's super philosophical I I think
that if he were here he would say he's
pragmatic now we could disagree as
whether he's effective or not but I
don't think that he's like reading John
Locke or reading uh lipenski or
something like that I just don't think
his mind operation I think kind of the
same way I don't think I don't think
Trump was an ideologue either I was
thinking of that I don't think Joe Biden
when it comes to how to get elected has
anything to do with unions or Latino
voters or anything like that I think Joe
Biden is thinking
what can I do period in terms of getting
power
you know I want my son to have these
special jobs where we can share a bank
account make money get me elected figure
it out Joe Biden's the kind of guy who
just throws money and you know at the
consultants in the organizations and
says figure out how to make it work I
don't think you know uh
you look at Donald Trump and I think he
was a guy who was like how do I get
these people on my side and he didn't do
a good job of it it's one of the reasons
in 2018 the midterms flip Democrat is
because people voted for Trump in 2016
didn't come out and vote for Republicans
because they didn't care it wasn't Trump
trump was ineffective at getting those
people to stand up for a kind of
movement I look at you know Pelosi and
Schumer and and truth be told like
Lindsey Graham especially Kevin McCarthy
and McConnell they're all very much Cut
From the Same Cloth they don't actually
care about any of these groups they go
to the Consultants
proximity to power I think Lindsey
Lindsey Graham wants to be in we got all
the stuff's happening we got to go to
super chats and we went a little long so
we'll go along with super chats my
apologies but been having fun so uh
smash that like button if you have not
already subscribe to this channel share
the share with your friends and let's
just read what people have to say
all right
not so stealthy Yeti says fauci caught
covet and had to hide
is that why he's been gone well fauci
came out uh and he was just like it's a
new variant ba2 I think it's called oh
boy all right Michael Brogan says Andrew
loved your Churchill video with whiskey
tribe thank you informative and funny
would you ever do something like that
again uh so for people that are
unfamiliar with this whiskey tribe is a
really fun YouTube program they're
really into whiskey uh they invited me
on because they wanted to see if we
could drink and smoke as much as Winston
Churchill in the day and I agreed to do
that and consumed a tremendous amount of
alcohol and about five cigars over the
course of the day my voice is not fully
recovered from it yet it was super fun I
could not lead a World War I could maybe
leave Belgium like I could lead a tiny
country while doing that I definitely
couldn't lead anything United Kingdom or
larger uh I would be interested in doing
something like that I wouldn't do it
super often a couple of people have
suggested Hunter S Thompson I know I
could not handle Hunter yeah so maybe
but I'm gonna take a breather for a
minute Churchill could drink it
prodigious amount so this is actually
funny
um we have we had the window open last
night in the studio oh boy and uh I was
recording with Sheamus some some you
know we were doing some bits and people
watching chicken City
could we're like whoa it sounds like
someone's getting yelled at because uh
what they really heard was me yelling as
Dr fauci so it was it was a brutal like
it was like 40 minutes I think of me
doing fauci's voice I thought I was
gonna hack up blood doing his voice
because it's you know he actually did
hack up blood I was like Tim The Show
Must Go On that's right you don't get to
step away from this right now
all right all right let's read some more
Mikhail Isaacson says coming soon Sweden
joins NATO NATO troops come to Sweden
just in time when it comes out that
Sweden helped uh well I can't read that
so NATO troops take Sweden oh also China
is going to find bio labs in Taiwan when
they evade in a couple of days weeks I
think is are you referring to like
justifications or something sorry
YouTube blocks actually some of what
your Super Chat was so I can't read it
all right
the lore Lodge says hey Tim know you've
been doing some more entertainment
focused stuff and we would love to be a
part of it uh well I'm not familiar with
what you guys do but we definitely are
working on some uh entertainment based
stuff for sure we're doing uh the Vlog
is going to be Shenanigans and comedic
bits nice so we have uh some comedic
bits we got Sheamus this guy helped with
some of that yeah this makes jokes yes
that's right you every now and again
daften says socialism is the ideology
communism is the pure implementation or
socialism respects some existing private
property and communism eliminates
private property I hear what you're
saying but I do think we kind of hit the
nail in the head in terms of you know
socialism being an economic system and
communism being the ideological system
though
all right let's grab some more stupid
shits let's see what we got can I move
on to Scotch while you're doing that
yeah go yeah go for it because we're
about halfway through three quarters
we're mostly well we should start
drinking right now yeah we went we went
a little long so we've got you know 15
or 20 more minutes we'll read something
oh great no I'll get drunk yeah go for
it okay but I'll be funny this ladder
half all right there you go rob short
says Sheamus will grow potatoes for
everyone so there is no food shortage
yes on this the day after the feast of
Saint Patrick you make a racist comment
towards me an irish-american and I'm
just trying to express my opinions
I was surprised no one did anything on
St Patrick's Day for you to be honest
yeah I thought something was going to
happen apparently uh your audience is
more respectful than you thought yeah no
no no I mean like I thought someone here
would get a cake it would have been nice
no like a green cake with no one who
cares that much about me I wore these
what happy St Patty's Day
I wore them yesterday and a day for you
and I do that that'll be
honestly until uh until you know the day
of and I was like oh really but it would
have been fun to have gotten like a
green cake with you like a leprechaun on
it and it's been fun
but I have to wear it because my name is
Sheamus you guys have passing privilege
you have passing privilege you can go
other places and tell people your name
and they won't know your ethnicity isn't
Timothy Daniel Irish yeah but Tim is a
name that a lot of people who are not
Irish will still use because it's more
normal sounding like no one has named
their kid Sheamus in the United States
for 80 years it's not one person not one
I'm the only one you can say see Miss
and say you're the only one I could well
people I mean people do when they read
my name off of paper
we're McGill's on my dad's side of the
family which is a Scottish name and I
looked into McGill McGill means son of a
stranger yeah
[Laughter]
great No One's Gonna try and Sack
McMaster
deliopolis says Tim do you ever get the
feeling that in about 12 months you'll
be talking about zelenski the same way
you talk about Dr fauci now he is the
Andrew Cuomo of 2022. he is indeed
without spoiling a joke that Sheamus
wrote oh boy yeah we so we're working
don't you worry we're working on a
cartoon about an owl of course we are so
that one was actually really easy we
recorded that like five minutes yeah and
then the other one took a half an hour
it's funny because the second one we
recorded is going to be much less
intensive with respect to the animation
work but it took a long time to record
all of the work was in the audio right
it was me doing the voice of Dr fauci
but you know Sheamus is directing so I
gotta keep doing the line over and over
again and getting the nuance and
everything right I'm a Diva as a
director but it sounds so there's like a
rough edit it's hilarious perfect yeah
oh man but actually I actually think the
other one might end up being funnier
just be excuse me they're both yours
after we laughed and laughed while
recording it he's funny listen all right
Donovan Davis says currently reading
Plato's the Plato's The Republic oh God
and it covers the topics to a t
reference the section uh Socrates is
discussing the hypothetical City and the
regime's rulers have said regimes note
that he says the rule rulers should be
philosophers of course they should and
good luck reading the Republic gosh yeah
centralized power is bad that's just
that's just about it you know every time
you get someone who thinks they know how
to make everything work they end up just
killing everybody the problem is over
extreme of in any direction is bad
because extreme pluralism you were
saying earlier is to the point where
it's like Live and Let Live to the point
where Communists are some dangerous
entity can come in and set up shop and
no one stops them because everyone's so
pluralist so you need Authority you just
gotta find that balance those
philosopher Kings like like this is all
government but in particular people that
are prone to philosopher king thinking
gov no government on the planet ever has
been able to mandate what you should
want in your heart right governments can
do they can do incentive they can't do
intentions and like the philosopher king
people never ever get that where they're
like well you have to be nice to these
people not only it doesn't work that way
like you have to uh everybody in your
company has to make X you're like fine
I'm gonna fire the bottom half of the
company
I have to read this next Super Chat oh
boy you ready for this one Ryan says I
think if I were a woman and I just
listened to Tim explain the Biden
Ukraine corruption I'd go get a
pregnancy test
what that's some deep knowledge that's
wild yeah that was a bit information
we'll start that was a good joke so um
and of course I'm gonna read the
compliments for myself yeah of course
all right sultry Cedar says Tim do you
think the Second Amendment right to keep
in bear arms extends to explosives such
as fireworks yes absolutely 100 it's
fireworks he's talking about nukes the
other day yeah I know can you buy a
cannon in America yes you can you can
you can you can do you have a cannon no
you should get a game yes look I've got
a civil war rifled musket over there
it's the same principle yeah you know
you're gonna stuff it with powder and
then put the ball in and then it's funny
that you know Joe Biden's like you can't
buy a cannon and it's like you could
always buy a candy I can still buy I
think you could crown I I think your
supporters would buy you a can they're
not that expensive if you ask people to
bike how much is a couple hundred bucks
for a cannon yeah so I could buy a
camera yes I'm gonna buy a cannon dude
that sounds great
you're talking about I'm gonna have a
long camera you have lost your Tactical
Advantage now that everyone knows this
no this is great like because I live in
Texas right but yeah I don't know any
guns so when people are like yeah like
what kind of gun you're like I own a
cannon like this one it's a cannon bring
it out to the Fourth of July fire
how much does a kayak cost
two three hundred dollars now imagine
going back several hundred years and
crafting one I'd imagine it would
actually be substantially more buying
power because you know right like
someone would take a long time to build
you and they probably they hand made
those kayaks now they're just a plastic
mold so same thing with cannons yes so I
can just so look literally I'm just
gonna go buy a cannon when we're done
searching by Canon right now let's see
if it yeah it's a big hunk of metal it's
not complicated I'm gonna get okay so
now hold on you want to get a Howitzer
all right now we're talking about I want
an ornamental cat I want a cannon where
like theoretically if somebody's
invading me I can irritate them briefly
yeah that's what I want I want to be
able to like go full of life I want to I
want to be able to put a hole through a
Volvo that's what I want
um I'm not not
steamcanons.com just a place where we
can look at canons if you're interested
I just first one that popped up you can
buy a tank
okay this is my new goal for the
political orphanage is to get my my
people to buy me a tank yeah I thought
you I thought everyone says you're on
the center when you argue with them so
yeah but I really love novelty and
owning a tank like I don't even care the
tank would be cool well we'll paint it
pink or something so I have a Centrist
it'll be great so I got in trouble
because I said that uh Second Amendment
covers nukes and biological weapons it
does it's not it's not it's not an
opinion it's a fact
now some people might not like that it
does and might argue that we shouldn't
allow people to have nukes Second
Amendment absolutely does cover any
weapon that anyone could have and this
is easily proven Halliburton and the
private organizations Lockheed Martin
they're private institutions that have
these weapons
they're not the government
do they control nukes no I don't know
about I don't know who who uh but look
the government doesn't make their
weapons they buy them from contractors
so Boeing makes the planes Boeing owns
them and Boeing does the tests on them
they control it they fly them that's
privately owned weapons I'm gonna be
honest with you I don't want to buy a
nuke I just like I see I thought you
liked Novelties
I'm gonna get the tank it seems like
everyone's gonna want to come over and
touch the nuke I'm gonna have to get
like an alarm system for my nuke I don't
want to do that that's what I get a tank
all right let's read this from art
vandelay he says Ian you need to read
Thomas Sowell in the 1960 black people
had 90 percent of uh of white per capita
income and 80 to parent homes Lyndon B
Johnson LBJ and the Dems Great Society
program that put this in reverse and no
one talks about how this destroyed
families I've heard a lot of stuff about
the Great Society and know very little
about it Thomas soul is a National
Treasure
he does not have a Nobel prize in
economics right oh my gosh yeah oh yeah
we can all agree on that Thomas amazing
except for great except for Ian yeah
his tank is great oh yeah and he didn't
paint his pink and you know what I don't
think he had a problem yeah
his Tank's see-through it's colorblade
now it just applies to geophysics you
can buy a tank but thanks to the
National Firearms Act it's very
difficult to get a crew served 50 BMG or
maybe maybe you wouldn't do 50. I think
people were saying there's another
caliber for crew service machine gun
what's a crew serve machine gun it's
like when you have that big mounted gun
and then one guy's holding the belt
butterfly trigger yeah yeah yeah what
Nancy Pelosi wanted on January 6th
that's right yeah she she asked for it
and they're like are you doing what yeah
machine gun well she wanted Cruz I think
she said belt fed but everyone was like
crew served
wow okay
I think she requested she requested it
specifically yeah and they told her like
you're crazy we're not doing that yes
like that you're gonna we're gonna do
riddle the walls of the buildings in DC
when guys are like
best crew served BMG I came up with the
Sig sauers
mg338 have you ever heard of that thing
heavy machine I think someone sent that
to me actually it says it Bridges the
gap between the crew served M2 Browning
heavy machine and the uh m240. well you
know sometimes I can't wait for my
homeowners association to have to talk
to me about the cannon I put in my front
yard and they look damn it Gerald it has
nothing to do with the fence it has
nothing to do with a pool you don't have
any jurisdiction here I'm keeping the
cat out of here I pay my dues that's
right that's my dues yeah show me I
can't own a camera
you can yeah one of the stories I was
reading about that I love to tell is
when the guy was in his tank firing a
full auto 50 caliber into his own like
Lake and the cops showed up and then he
stopped and he's like he's like what can
I do for you and the cops were like is
this your tank he's like yes it is and
they're like this your land yes it is
and they went have a nice day and they
just took off you know what you have to
do you just have to get a bunch of
cannons by every single window and then
have them half poking out like a pirate
ship yeah No One's Gonna rob you yeah
and then let's see if that hoi tries to
come out that's right that HOA is gonna
come pick a fight gosh my blazer
collection will be safe yes I love it
all right let's read some more
blank out says member here with an idea
request please read you know the Biden
barisma better than most create a high
quality docu-series walking through the
evidence with visual aids clear citation
video news Clips I will increase my
monthly member fee for it that's a good
idea let's do a cartoon Let's do an
educational cartoon on it but that would
be like 20 minutes but honestly you'd be
surprised we could talk about it later
but I'm working with the foundation for
economic education for like five years
to compress these really complex ideas
into short cartoon so we might not be
able to get all of it in there but I
think we can get a really good
comprehensive thing I kind of feel like
there's people uh well
I have a good grasp of like an overhead
view of a lot of these issues you know
and then I read I read Matt tahibi's
reporting on this and he got into the
nitty-gritty and he he pulled up some
facts which were absolutely astounding
notably that Victor shock and the
prosecutor was invent was investigating
Michael which the media denied over and
over again and then he came out and said
a cursory review of Ukrainian court
documents show I think it was like or
legal documents that there were like 12
different active investigations and and
led several that had been suspended but
were still active like that that had
been on hold but we're still active uh
when Biden came in and did this so we
have to pull up a lot of that old
research and stuff and make sure we get
all the facts right but we can do it
that'd be awesome yeah that would be a
good 20 minutes that'd be really
entertaining if it was well animated I
would sit there and watch it that was
just great listening to you earlier we
couldn't I mean if we were going to do
we could do multiple versions too like
if it was 20 minutes would have to be
some infographics type thing and even
that's a stretch but I'm telling you you
can compress some really complex things
into short videos if you know how to do
the visuals right yeah
all right Austin Walter it says simplest
way to show the truth divide go to CNN
or MSNBC and look for external links
there will be none then go to Newsmax
fox or daily wire and you can see the
citations same with water Crowder yeah
they cite everything yep
yeah it's fascinating that's why we use
News Guard you've ever heard of them
they're they're very biased but they
give ratings to various news outlets
it's a good idea well I like using it
because
when people are like you know Tim Poole
pushed this story or whatever I'm like
take it up with News Guard like it's
their certification not mine so
I wonder how they feel about it they get
accused of bias all the time though from
the left and the right so I'm imagining
it's not an easy business to be in
trying to be like this site is good the
site is bad but look they give the daily
wire a green rating uh they get Fox News
when when they gave News Guard gave Fox
News a green certification the left lost
their minds they're like Fox News is
lying in fake news and the News Guard
people were like no they're not like Fox
News legitimately reports the news you
just don't like to disagree with her I
used to work at Fox Business and I've
said there's there's a difference
between Fox News and fox opinion and you
can take your difference with Fox
opinion but that is opinion right the
actual people that are writing the
stories and we were rigorously fact
checking things as well if I put
something in a script I had to be very
careful about the facts going into it oh
wow that's interesting vosh says Mac is
Gaelic for Son of yeah so it's neither
Scottish or Irish in origin same with MC
it's just shortened so M's but MC is
generally the Irish spelling at Mac is
generally decided but yeah
I know but no it is son of no no we're
still bastards okay I can't speak for
you yeah no we for sure are yeah you're
like oh no I can tell yeah all right
Matthew heading out says this has been
the best conversation and debate I've
heard in years I mean it literally just
awesome from everyone on the show
tonight solid 20. thank you very much
yeah I think this is actually a blast
that's why I went a little long because
we're having a good time it was great
and can I like because that's what Ian
said about religion but everything else
it's also it's really refreshing to be
able to have a conversation like this
with someone right where we can come in
like I still like you I'm having a good
time and to be able to be able to but
you're close you're close it was
enjoyable because it was one of those
nights where I'm like I'm not saying
much Sheamus didn't say much but you
guys were in it and it was really good
I'm gonna re-watch I think it was mostly
me going off yeah but the the Ukraine
stuff he screamed at him you smacked it
yeah
looking at things from two polarities
and looking at things like I think he
said what was the the different circles
that are all connecting to each other
Venn diagrams
I'm a big Venn diagram guy well uh
anyway it was fun thank you I enjoyed
that there are interesting
visualizations about like how YouTube
groups
um the left and the right the funny
thing is there was this researcher who
did an assessment of YouTube channels
left and right and there were a small
handful of channels that were separate
from all there was left Center and right
and then exclusively critical of left
and it was funny because I was like why
do you think that you know how do you
come up with that category and it's like
well you're only criticizing this one
group and I'm like it's it's just weird
that that idea is born like that
worldview was born out of
how I describe this
if if you can't understand that there
are people who are on the left that are
critical of critical race Theory and you
know that kind of stuff you're confused
by what you're watching it doesn't fit
your world view so you have to give it
its own isolated I was like is it simple
enough to just say we are centrists we
are people who have left-wing political
views and are critical of people that
are supposedly on the left so that's not
an exclusively critical of left thing
because we also espouse left-wing views
yet I want to make a point here because
this is really really important it's a
massive part of the puzzle there are
people who exclusively criticize the
left but that is a very different thing
to do from a left-wing perspective
versus a right-wing perspective so Jimmy
Dore criticizes the left from a
left-wing perspective and says they're
not really standing for the values that
they claim to be standing for they're
hypocritical I criticized the left from
a right-wing perspective it is totally
different but we're criticizing the same
group but for different reasons so to
love us in the exact same category and
say we're ideological allies is
ridiculous the weirdest thing to me even
though I would agree with him on some
things you know Jimmy Dore is I I think
Jimmy's a socialist you know I always
say I think because I don't want to put
words in his mouth but I'm pretty sure
he's like pretty left and it's weird to
me that I'm not left enough for the left
to be forced you know when they when
they talk about Jimmy Dore they call him
on the left and put an asterisk next to
his name because they're like but he's a
you know shill for Russia or whatever
they're saying about him and for me I'm
like
I I made a video supporting the green
New Deal what is that bug I don't know
he doesn't have a stinger on him or a
probiscus so I don't think he's gonna
suck your blood he's a weird giant bug
that's from Texas I'm sorry I brought
that with me yeah
all right let's see well I also bad bug
sorry about that oh my gosh Andrew
there's one there's one more thing I
want to mention with respect to this
often people saying that they aren't a
member of a particular group can at
least in some circumstances indicate
that that group's values it can't
indicate that No One Believes it anymore
it can also integrate that indicate that
that group's values have become so
ubiquitous that people hold their values
without acknowledging it so oftentimes
people will say things like you know I
don't uh believe in feminism but I
believe X Y and Z referring to more like
classically feminist values and what
they're essentially saying is I give a
cent to all the things forwarded by
feminists 100 years ago I don't like
this current version but in some sense
they're still promoting feminist
assumptions I think the issue the same
with left-wing assumptions when people
criticize the left from the left they're
still promoting left-wing assumptions so
it's not the same thing as being on the
right right at all left and right don't
actually describe politics they describe
tribes so when someone says Tim pool is
clearly on the left it's because they're
referring to try but not policy when
people say Jimmy Dore is you know a
leftist but he's a he's a right winger
and they're confused by it it's because
his politics are too similar to theirs
but he doesn't like he's you know he
doesn't like them I think you're right
about that we're living in a really
really tribal time it's a very tribal
Time by Design By Design uh like I I
think that the political parties the
people in power uh know that it's a lot
harder to win elections based on
actually coming up with solutions to
problems it's a lot easier to get people
to vote out of fear and hate and so
they're doing that and
um we we live in a weird period where
people don't really care about what you
think they care about the the word
choice you use to describe what you
think did you say Patriot or social
justice that's all I care about dude I
saw the Jesse smallett sentencing and
the judge was like the word that starts
with an n
and then he went on and I'm like you
can't even in a court of law you can't
even say that word out loud like this is
what the world is coming to that's a
great example of secular versus
non-secular thinking right like so I I'm
gonna make the case that like
um Uber progressives tend to be like
religious right yeah yeah absolutely So
like um like and I'm saying this is the
friendly low wattage agnostic here in
the group I'm saying this is the secular
person at the table I think that there's
a tremendous amount of people in the
United States that would have been what
we call religious 100 years ago and
they've taken that religiosity and
applied it to politics and a good
example of that is do you believe in the
concept of magic words so like a magic
word would be I would say to your point
Ian
um there are certain words you can say
in a court of law and it has no moral a
program associated with it or uh yeah a
program or if you're in your basement
you say it by yourself but there are
other people are like no it is a cosmic
affront to a moral to morality to ever
utter a certain word in the same way you
can't say like Jehovah because that like
like right so that's that division
between
and there are people who completely
disagree with that world view who know
the people of institutional power and
believe in that worldview will destroy
you
look at Joe Rogan yeah they came after
him I think you're right Joe Rogan like
what did he get he initially got in
trouble because he was bringing on
different voices regarding vaccines and
whatnot which by the way is how you
challenge ossified Orthodoxy like when
you've when you've got a a an opinion
that becomes not only ubiquitous but
unquestioned that's when you make really
bad decisions you need to have people
asking questions the challenge Orthodoxy
and a lot of the time they're cranks and
a lot of the time they're they're from
the periphery until they're right
because like the the heliocentric
worldview was crank until it was
challenged right he got in trouble for
that it didn't stick and then what did
they do they went and found examples of
him saying the n-word that I were taken
out of context and and then well he's
racist you have to cancel them now right
and then he he caved you know we had
Papa John on the show and they really
it's it's all lies do you know Papa
John's story Papa John was on a private
phone call he was uh having a it was
like a business meeting
it's been years since I talked about it
but he was complaining about how Colonel
Sanders used the n-word and no one
seemed to care but he actually said the
full word so he was castigating somebody
for using the n-word and they destroyed
it they destroyed his life really they
kicked him out of the company they took
his name off of schools they they they
they they news stories are publishing he
used the n-word that the news stories
about Joe Rogan were that he used the
n-word no no he said it descriptively it
in criticizing the use of it context and
intention matter but this is why I say
you know look at a certain point after
you know 10 years of living through this
you got to recognize there is when
whatever factions they are one is lying
all the time
the right Falls for it sometimes truth
be told but I I can look if you go
through name a name name a story from
black lives matter with one of their
riots that turned out to be the way they
described it
anything I don't know I'm drinking now I
mean look the latest example being Ahmed
Arbury you said oh that guy who was the
jogger that he was not jogging
objectively not jogging
and uh even the prosecutor in the case
against the guys said he was a felony
burglary suspect who was being pursued
the question is did they have a right to
pursue him or not the jury decided they
didn't that's why they were convicted
now they also got the hate crime charges
but I get this the guy who filmed it got
convicted yep all he did was saw Aubrey
running and started filming what was
happening and they said he was in it so
he goes to prison too for the rest of
his life what he was in a car following
behind and because he was falling behind
they made it seem like he was pinning
the guy in when he was just so here's
I'll give you this like the primary
evidence they have in this was provided
by that guy yes and now he's going to
prison yep for the rest of his life
clearly they lied when you're locking up
the guy who presented the evidence it
sounds to me more like they they're
saying you embarrassed us so you guys
can all go you know go rot for all we
care but what's the official narrative
that a guy was jogging 20 miles from his
house in work boots and that some
racists pinned him and then killed him
the real story is a neighborhood plagued
by burglaries the police went around and
said here's a picture of the guy
security camera footage showed him
committing felony burglary because
people need to understand I don't know
if it was felony burglary but uh people
need to understand that burglary is not
breaking into someone's house and
robbing them it's breaking into
someone's house we're learning this the
hard way right now so when they had
evidence of him entering a home it's not
trespassing the police then say here's
the guy a gun was stolen a couple weeks
later they see him
these guys should not have chased after
him in my opinion
but they decided to they they uh um they
cut him off they went past him on a
different street and stopped one of the
guys got out he had a shotgun probably
because I could be speculating but this
guy they believed may have stolen a gun
maybe perhaps it's wrong to make that
assumption but someone did steal a gun
and this guy was a suspect so you're not
it's not illegal to stand in a street
with a gun
Ahmed Aubry then ran around the right
side of the truck and then as soon as he
got to the front of the truck jumped
left and attacked one of the McMichaels
the young one who had the gun fighting
for the shotgun trying to take it it's
called dual possession the shotgun went
off shooting the chest and killing him
the guy who filmed it is going to prison
these two guys were the media said they
lynched a guy who was jogging the real
story is much more nuanced than this and
the reality is a couple of guys were
probably dumb to do what they did were
trying to stop what they thought was a
burglary and perhaps they were racist in
their assumptions about him but either
way if the cops go to your house and say
this is the guy someone's running around
in work boots having been seen on
security camera after a gun was stolen I
wouldn't be surprised if someone in the
neighborhood freaked out about it it's
tragic man but what needs to be brought
up is Ahmed Arbury attacked them you
could argue that he was justified if you
surround if there's a guy behind me in a
car and two guys pull up and waits out
gets out with a shotgun maybe maybe I'd
attack him too right my interpretation
my point is just real quick is that the
media lied media life if everybody in
that neighborhood had had a lawn Cannon
which is what I'm planning to get when
we conclude this show I don't think that
would have happened just one launch just
a single lawn Cannon I thought you're
gonna put them in the windows didn't we
I mean like but in in all seriously what
I could afford my own home instead of a
duplex yes
hey hold on you got those cannons
sticking out of your window you're gonna
put it but in all seriousness whoever
was burglarized in the neighborhood be
it Arbor otherwise stole one of their
guns so it's like even when these people
had set up security cameras and were
armed it was months of this going on and
it's much more complicated than that so
you can argue these guys were in the
wrong and it shouldn't have happened and
I'm saying personally I'm sad that
anybody died
but that's not what the media said and
to this day the left will tell you a guy
who was innocently jogging was lynched
that has been every single story
remember hands up don't shoot that was a
lie Michael Brown did not have his hands
up the corners I think it was Obama's
just Department found that he was
actually had his hands down and he was
lunging towards the cop uh Darren Wilson
but they've they've lied and they've
written they've I mean look at the
George Floyd story everything they said
about that man boy did it turn out to be
false should anybody die in these
situations no are cops responsible in
many of these cases yes but they just
keep lying to us and they justify
violence and destruction I'm Gonna Keep
ranting about this because I do so often
so you know we'll wrap it up there we've
gone a bit long I don't know if you guys
have anything you want to say before we
bounce out
um I've mentioned before that the
Catholic church had killed Galileo in
fact no they just put him in prison yeah
uh for saying that the sun was the
center of the universe so speak he was
it was fake news at the time and they
can't tried to cancel him he did die in
prison but the church didn't actually
kill him I want to want to clarify that
also the brave search engine which I've
been experimenting with I've been in
touch with business Ops over at Brave
and there are ways you can go to
search.brave.com settings and fix your
Brave search engine from there with your
Brave browser alright everybody head
over to timcast.com become a member
thanks for hanging out this Friday night
you can follow the show at timcast IRL
you can follow me at timcast you want to
shout anything out Andrew sure again I
had a fun time this is great yeah
anytime how was the scotch it was good
it was uh very good which was strong I'm
pretty sure I got The Cask strength one
because my head is swimming did you take
the school back or whatever it's called
yes the one of the blue like ceramic jug
yes that's what I took in it it is
hitting me hard
Tim anytime somebody can make me think I
viewed that as a really good
conversation and you made me think
tonight and I'm gonna have to like uh
kind of uh mull with some of the stuff
you said but I very much enjoyed it I
appreciate you letting me come on
absolutely anybody that enjoyed me go
check out the political orphanage uh
thank you very much Lydia and I'll say
like at least going back to like the
foreign policy stuff I'd recommend the
last episode I did it's called Uh how to
prevent or provoke stupid Wars and I
what I basically do is just get into
underlying Ira theory about realism
liberalism Marxism social constructivism
and try and get past kind of that
surface level partisan noise get into
the fundamentals of what's happening and
uh welcome people to come check that out
what's your Twitter you have Twitter too
right at Mighty Heaton love it come hang
out I mostly just do horse jokes on
Twitter I don't I don't really get into
Political fights on Twitter that's just
funny stuff on Twitter awesome
go check out my YouTube Channel right
now Freedom Tunes go look at it one of
those we disagree very much and even Ian
with whom I disagree on a number of
things endorse the latest videos
than just fouchy man come on I mean look
Tim I know I know you have to keep the
lights here but if bouchi's not in the
news I'm not going to violate the
Artistic integrity of my work I was
thinking about that though I was like
you know now that fauci's out of the
news cycle I was like what am I gonna
I'm not gonna be on freedom tunes
anymore I swear you're Bill Gates your
Bill Gates is next level
but I'm just ripping off Family Guy's
Impressions even better uh oh and Ian
Crossland Ian crossland.net hit me up
there I think that's everything for
tonight see you guys next week and
follow Graphics we'll be riding uh space
elevators tethered with graphene
amalgams
I just wanted to say during this
conversation about crew served machine
guns children are perfect for training
to serve machine machine gun functions
so if you want to have a family that's a
great reason to do so or send your
orphans to me I'll take them out perfect
I love it that's a great plan Andrew
you guys may follow me on Twitter and
minds.com at sour patchlitz all right
everybody I just want to point out uh I
didn't kill that bug some people were
saying darn it killed the bug I tried to
I dressed it survived and I just want to
make sure you all know that thanks for
hanging out we'll see you all next time
bye guys
what wait
go to youtube.com uh search for chicken
City subscribe to chicken City and watch
chicken City Live okay it is chickens
being chickens and chickens are funny
and we'll see you all next time bye guys